[musique]
Alexander Del Val, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Alexandre
Delval, euh géopolitologue depuis une
trentaine d'années, euh que dire
d'autres ? Méditerranéen, euh maire
espagnol, per sicilien, fruit de
l'immigration, réussi l'époque où on on
fabriquait des Français d'ailleurs, même
à distance puisque mon père est devenu
français euh entre la Tunisie et
l'Algérie. C'est à distance qu'il est
devenu un français. Autre chose, ancien
cancre mais qui a repris les études une
fois que j'ai eu une une vocation. C'est
venu très tard. J'avais raté mon premier
bac. Ensuite, j'ai eu un bac candidat
libre à Marseille au lycée Saint-Exupéri
et après je me suis plus arrêté. Pas
science pour Paris tout de suite,
Science Pox, après prépar Science pour
Paris. J'ai raté l'ENA mais je suis pas
du tout aigri. Je pense c'était une
bénédiction et ensuite j'ai bifurqué
plutôt vers la préparation d'une d'une
thèse que j'ai fait en très longtemps en
plusieurs étapes. Je commence avec Yve
Lacos qui était notre maître à tous en
géopolitique et après je l'ai repris
avec quelqu'un d'autre à à Montpellier
3. Donc j'ai un doctorat de géopolitique
mais soutenu en histoire contemporaine
et un HDR ce ne sont que des papiers. Je
ne dis pas pour me vanter de quoi que ce
soit. Un HDR s'est habilité à diriger
les recherches en sciences politiques à
Nice Université Côte d'Azur. Que dire
d'autre ? J'ai écrit une vingtaine de
livres surtout entre la France et
l'Italie. Livre de géopolitique. J'ai
commencé beaucoup sur l'islamisme. J'en
avais marre d'être monsieur islam. Et
après, je me suis dit comme j'enseigne
la géopolitique à l'IPAC Business
School, une vieille école de commerce
française, et bien je me suis dit faut
peut-être aussi écrire des livres qui ne
parlent pas forcément et mes trois
derniers livres ne parlent pas de
l'islamisme dont le le nouvel ordre post
occidental. Mon dernier ouvrage,
on en parlera.
Voilà. Merci. Et qui ne parle pas de
l'islamisme ? parce que je pense que il
faut parler de manière globale et même
quand j'ai parlé de l'islamisme, j'ai
toujours parlé de l'islamisme en parlant
également de la Russie ou de l'Union
soviétique et des Américains et du jeu
de l'Occident très trouble vis-à-vis de
ce thème
accessoirement vous êes accessoirement
vous êtes habilité secret défense.
J'ai été habilité confidentielle défense
he je veux pas me vanter de ce que je ne
suis pas au SGDN quand j'ai fait un
passage quand j'étais fonctionnaire
c'est là que j'ai connu Caroline
Galacteros Éric Desé et d'autres on
était moi en tout cas moi j'étais
confidentiel défense puisque on
analysait des dossiers qui parfois
venaient du renseignement mais c'est un
service du premier ministre hein pour la
politique de défense de la nation et je
suis pas resté longtemps parce que mon
supérieur le colonel le cudenec j'étais
en stage de titularisation, il me disait
"Vous, vous avez une grande gueule, vous
êtes libre, vous avez envie d'écrire et
de parler, cassez-vous parce que on nous
écoute pas. Vous allez faire des
analyses avec des un peu de
renseignement, vous allez faire des
notes que les hommes politiques ne
liront pas." D'ailleurs, on faisait des
nocs avec des on faisait une demi-page à
qu
sûr qu'il comprennent et on nous disait
ça ne sert à rien. Et à l'époque, moi je
travaillais sur l'islamisme radical et
nous avions tous les dossiers sur les
salafistes qui déjà récupéré nos
compatriotes musulmans qu'on aurait pu
beaucoup mieux intégrer et déjà nos
hommes politiques laisser nos
compatriotes musulmans offerts sur un
plateau d'argent à des islamistes dont
nous savions exactement le profil. nous
pouvions les juguler et là j'ai compris
effectivement si lui-même un vieux de la
vieille avait presque à la retraite s'il
me dit casse-toi ne reste surtout pas
dans notre monde va écrire des livres
voilà pourquoi ensuite j'ai bifurqué
vers une fonction publique moins moins
encadrée j'ai quand même gardé un un un
pseudo parce que on a le devoir de
réserve mais j'ai écrit mes premiers
livres sous pseudo et ensuite j'ai
quitté la fonction publique et j'en suis
très fier.
Bah écoutez ça tombe bien est-ce qu'on
va pouvoir commencer avec ça ? Comment
ça se fait euh que l'anticipation,
la préconnaissance, les conduites euh
les préconisations euh pour défendre nos
intérêts économiques, défendre notre
territoire, défendre peut-être l'Europe
? Euh pourquoi ce censé nous faire du
jus de cerveau, du concentré de jus de
cerveau à l'attention de nos prises de
décisions les plus régaliennes et les
plus angulaires
pour la France ? En fait, pourquoi il y
a plus de courrois de transmission entre
le renseignement, l'analyse, le
prospectiviste
et la situation que le pays est en train
de traverser ? C'est une question qui me
tare. Euh, j'ai toujours été patriote.
J'ai été formé par le général Galois,
l'inventeur de la force de frappe
nucléaire française. La dissuasion du
faible fort. Vous savez, avec les autres
généraux de l'apocalypse, il m'a
transmis avec d'autres gaulistes qui
m'ont donné des chances quand j'étais
plus jeune, notamment Matthéoli et
d'autres grands gaulistes. J'ai été
formé dans cette idée de l'intérêt
national et j'ai toujours été frappé de
voir que il n'y a plus aucune conscience
de l'intérêt et je sais que c'est lourd
ce que je dis dans chez nos hommes
politiques. En tout cas, les les grands,
les autres, c'est différent. Mais parmi
les grands hommes politiques qui ont qui
ont qui ont commandé la France he au
destiné de la France depuis une
trentaine d'années, aucun n'a
véritablement eu le sens de l'intérêt
national, de l' de l'intérêt collectif,
l'intérêt patriotique, enfin l'esprit
patriotique encore moins. Et ça explique
la c'est la raison pour laquelle quand
les services de renseignement de
n'importe quel pays occidental ont
alerté sur des erreurs que commettaient
nos hommes politiques, et bien ils ils
ne les ont jamais écouté, sauf au
dernier moment, exemple Hollande, ils
n'écoutent pas les Syriens qui lui
donnent une liste de nous tout tous nos
terroristes en Syrie parce que
Squarchini avait reçu l'ancien
Bernard que vous avez peut-être reçu
ici. Hollande est emmerdé parce que
finalement il est un peu en porte à fau
et et et Hollande alors Vals, il se
trouve que je le connais bien, il aime
pas quand je l'écorche parce que je
l'aime beaucoup humainement et je
l'avais un peu un jour critiqué sur
quelque chose. Donc je vais pas parler
de Vals mais que je salue au passage.
Mais Hollande a a beaucoup regretté
d'avoir pas de ne pas avoir écouté les
Syriens à travers la liste qu'il avait
reçu et ensuite il est devenu le plus
grand killer, le plus grand tueur de
djihadistes en Syrie. Il a essayé de se
rattraper mais on aurait pu le faire en
amont. Si on avait écouté les services
de renseignement français intérieur qui
nous avertissaient d'une liste des
Syriens qui savaient parfaitement tous
les francophones qui s'entraînaient en
Syrie, on pouvait peut-être empêcher le
le Bataclan. Et ça c'est un exemple
parmi tant d'autres. De même que la CIA,
la CIA a souvent préconisé des choses un
peu tordues, mais elle a souvent aussi
averti, attention, il y a des risques.
On a on on même les Américains n'ont pas
toujours et ou même rarement écouté la
CIA et euh les services espagnols avec
qui euh les
services turcs
et les services turcs. Alors, les
services turcs sont quand même très
compétents.
le le le mythe a joué un jeu extrêmement
habile en Syrie, un peu en force
d'appoint de l'opération Timber Sikamor,
l'opération de la CIA qui visait à
renverser Bachar Al-Assad en aidant des
islamistes voire aussi des des
djihadistes. En fait, c'était pas qu'une
opération CIA, il y avait le mythe en
appui et les pays du golf. Et ça a
abouti à Joulani. Joulani, c'est une
création postume, enfin 10 ans plus
tard, c'est une création d'un programme
de la CIA avec les services secrets
turc. Ils ont très bien joué. Il faut
reconnaître qu'ils sont très forts. Les
ils ont des vrais services secrets qui
s'occupent de la patrie et même de
l'empire de l'empire du néoempire
ottoman.
Là, on va se polariser ou du moins se
concentrer ou faire la mise au point.
Décrivez-moi le conflit le conflit
russoau-rainien. Ah,
à partir de 2014, même de 2009
jusqu'aujourd'hui.
Synthétisez-moi ça en quelques phrases
ou
et ensuite on va creuser quelques
parties.
D'accord. Alors, le conflit ukrainien
à partir de 2014, en fait, faut
à partir de 2009,
à partir de 2009, alors à partir de
disons disons que 2008, c'est une c'est
une c'est la date moi que je mets dans
dans mon livre. euh 2008, c'est SarkoZi
et Merkel, la l'Allemagne et la France
qui ne veulent pas que la que la
l'Ukraine euh bien entendu et la
Geéorgie rentre dans l'OTAN. C'est pas
un vrai véto, c'est un blocage et euh là
on on a une possibilité d'empêcher la le
la montée en puissance et cette future
guerre de haute intensité. Mais quelques
années plus tard euh enfin à partir de
2010 plutôt euh les prusses entre
guillemets retrouve un chef qui est élu
démocratiquement avec observation de
l'OSCE Yanukovic et les Américains sont
pas du tout contents et l'OIL l'ordre
international libéral donc le le le
c'est le démocrate offshore he l'empire
américain est globaliste et les
atlantistes ne sont pas contents puisque
la Russie avait perdu le contrôle de
l'Ukraine et les prorusses reviennent au
pouvoir voir 5 ans après la la la
l'alternance procidentale de la première
révolution orange et c'est là que pas
uniquement George Soros comme le disent
les complotistes mais aussi Albert
Einstein Foundation Canvas de de
National Indovment for Democracy Voice
of America, plein d'organisation
notamment on retrouve le point de Canvas
et de l'association HP port qui a
commencé avec des anciens de Solidarnos
qui ensuite fait ont fait tomber
Milosevic par des par des manif
manifestation de jeunes étudiants qui
ont été plus efficaces que les bombes de
l'OTAN et les anciens de H port eux font
la révolution Kmara et et d'autres et
por en Ukraine Kmara en Geéorgie donc
2009 2010 2011 c'est la préparation
d'une d'une
réaction au fait que les Russes ont
repris en main l'Ukraine et là 2013 une
révolution qui commence doucement. On a
pas mal de vidéos d'ailleurs des
drapeaux européens hein, des jeunes des
on on se rappelle de la vidéo "I am
Ukrainian" d'une jeune fille qui dit
"Bah, on veut juste l'Europe, on veut la
paix" et cetera. et euh et elle montre
des braves ouvriers très disciplinés
avec leurs casques qui sortent tout
droit des mines. C'est en fait c'est la
mise en scène mais il y a il y a des
jeunes sincères, je les comprends, qui
ne veulent pas euh perdre l'Eldorado
européen parce que un certain Baroseo,
je pense que peu de gens en parlent et
moi j'en parle beaucoup dans mon livre
tout en détail, euh Baroso, l'ancien
président de la Commission européenne
dit qu'il faut absolument que monsieur
Nenukovist choisisse. Il doit choisir
soit la Russie soit l'Europe. Mais s'il
choisit l'Europe, il doit renoncer à la
Russie. Or, il y a des zones économiques
et des libres échanges importante avec
des normes. Yanukovic dit "Je ne peux
pas tout de suite bifurquer dans la
l'accord d'association avec l'Union
européenne parce que moi j'ai 80 % du
budget de de de la richesse ukrainienne,
c'est avec les Russes. Donc il faut me
laisser du temps." Il dit "Je vais
suspendre." Mais la désinformation de
Baroso et aussi des Américains et des
démocrates américains et des sénateurs
même républicains comme John McCain mais
aussi de de de plein de dirigeants
européens, ils vont tous aller dans le
Maidan et ils vont dire "C'est horrible
ce Yanukovic, je veux priver son peuple
de la prospérité européenne." Il refuse
pardon avec Victoria
avec Luland bien sûr. Victoria Luland,
on connaît sa conversation avec
l'ambassadeur
américain en Ukraine où elle dit "On va
retourner comme une crêpe les
dirigeants, on va mettre quelqu'un qui
nous est favorable. Tout cela est très
connu et je suis sûr que dans votre
chaîne, on en a parlé beaucoup en détail
mais Baroso, on oublie souvent sa
responsabilité parce que en disant à
Yanukovic, c'est nous ou rien, c'est
l'accord d'association avec l'Union
européenne ou rien, il le met dans dans
un piège terrible." Yanukovic, il est
ennuyé parce que il peut pas non plus
déplaire à Poutine et 80 % de de son
économie avec la Russie. On oublie ça.
Et les normes sont pas les mêmes dans
deux zones douanières différentes parce
qu'il y a aussi le projet eurasiatique
de de Poutine enfin de des Russes avec
les tous les anciens satellites ex-union
soviétiques et donc Yanukovic est
coincé. Ensuite, on sait aujourd'hui que
le dérapage violent, ce ne sont pas que
des Ukrainiens pro Yanukovic
gouvernementaux qui tirent sur des
passants. On sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a
des snipers et on sait aujourd'hui qu'il
y a même des Ukrainiens côté proinien
snipers qui veulent faire déraper la
révolution. Et c'est là que le groupe
Azof mais aussi Pravie sector secteur
droit des mouvements d'extrême droite
que les Russes qualifient de nazi dans
leur narratif mais c'est quelques
nostalgiques de gens qui ont collaboré
avec euh euh les nazis euh que l'on que
je dirais plutôt extrême droite et et
avec quelques néonazis qui sont le cœur
des admirateurs bien sûr de Pandera,
Stéphane Pandera et cetera et donc des
des c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui est un
admirateur de gens qui ont fait la cho
Bah, ils sont un peu moins doux que les
premiers révolutionnaires et et là, ils
sont utiles pour les Américains et pour
ceux qui font de l'ingénierie politique,
babillard et tout ça.
Absolument, absolument. Là, ils sont
utiles parce que ceux-là, ils aiment en
découdre. C'est c'est quand même des
vrais suprémacistes, c'est des vrais
russophobes mais violents. Euh, ils
rêvent de tuer du russe. Donc
effectivement, ceux-là, ils sont très
utiles pour faire déraper la révolution.
Et c'est la technique de Ginharp. Jean
Charp, l'homme qui a créé Albert
Einstein Foundation, qui a à la fois
formé la première révolutionnaire du
printemps arabe, la révolution du Jasmin
en Tunisie que j'ai bien connu, Lina
Benhini et qui a formé aussi la plupart
des révolutionnaires en Geéorgie, en
Ukraine. Et bien c'est là qui qui que
que son son son système rentre en
action. Il va pousser à accuser l'autre
de utiliser son sa force contre sa
propre population. Ça c'est sourcé tout
ça. C'est
Ah oui, c'est sourcé. Dans mon livre,
tout est sourcé. Alors Gincharpe a
expliqué d'ailleurs hein, dans un livre
de la de la dictature à la à la
démocratie, Jein Charp explique tout
cela, hein. C'est donc le président de
Albert Einstein Foundation. Il a réuni
des psychologues, les anciens de la CIA,
des colonels, des des spécialistes de la
programmation neurolinguistique. Il a
élaboré un système qui et il se réfère
souvent à la Boessie. Il dit, "Puisque
pouvoir ne tient que par la loyauté, par
la soumission volontaire qui crée une
loyauté, il suffit de diffuser l'idée
que la loyauté peut être diminuée et un
jour, on va faire en sorte que les gens
ne se soumettent plus et ils vont faire
tomber le dictateur parce que même un
pouvoir dictatorial ou autoritaire ou
illibéral, il a quand même besoin d'un
minimum de consensus et de et de
légitimité. Hors la légitimité, elle
donne le droit au monopole de la
violence selon Max Weber. Donc si je
pousse euh l'ennemi, celui que je veux
faire tomber, à abuser de son pouvoir et
si en le provoquant je pousse je le
pousse à tirer sur des populations
civiles, il y aura forcément bien sûr
des victimes innocentes qui vont mourir
ou qui vont avoir le visage ensanglanté.
C'est là que les gens formés par
l'association de Gincharp doivent faire
des photos, des films, euh des vidéos
qu'ils mettent sur internet et c'est
comme ça que ça dérape ensuite le
pouvoir perd sa légitimité puisque même
les militaires, les policiers ne veulent
plus servir un pouvoir qui tue des
femmes, des enfants ou des braves
ouvriers. Et c'est comme ça que les
révolutions arabes et les révolutions de
velour ont été préparées. George Soros
lui-même s'est vélivas
on il suffit de consulter les les
associations comme Canvas, National
Indovment for Democracy Usade qui ont
tout travaillé en reprenant le kit le
mode d'emploi de Gincharp. Donc j'invite
nos auditeurs à vérifier parce que faut
vérifier bien sûr, je pourrais mentir.
Donc ils peuvent tout ce que je dis ils
peuvent retrouver aujourd'hui, c'est
très connu. Ce sont des cas d'école pour
les techniques de communication, le PR,
le public relation parce que toutes ces
associations comme celle de Gin Charp,
elles ont été utilisées le parce que Gin
Charp, c'est un universitaire au départ
qui est contre la guerre du Vietnam. Il
a créé tout ça dans une bonne intention.
C'est un fils de pasteur protestant. il
est humaniste, il dit "Je veux plus de
guerres sanglantes." Donc je vais
inventer les guerres par action civile,
les guerres non sanglantes. Mais sa
méthode a été reprise par la CIA, par le
Seid, par la NED, par les frères
musulmans, hein, dans le printemps
arabe. Les frères musulmans ont récupéré
ces techniques pour faire échapper la
révolution au aux imberes gentils,
laïques, procidentaux et ensuite ça a
été récupéré par les islamistes. Donc
c'est vraiment un mode
pas que un berbe. Alors, quand je dis
Hberg, parce qu'il y a une une affiche
très intéressante des laïques euh de la
révolution du 14 février euh au au Maroc
qui reprenait un imber gentil qui
faisait un strapontin pour l'islamiste,
lui barbu. C'est pour ça que je prenais
l'expression unberbe contre la hogra. On
voyait l'image pendant la révolution du
printemps arabe qui a qui n'a pas réussi
au Maroc parce que les Marocains étaient
très malins, ils ont réussi à à à à
mettre les frères musulmans au pouvoir
pour les pour les laisser s'enfoncer.
Oui.
Et respecté d'ailleurs.
Très respecté. Ah, le roi. Mes mes
étudiants marocains disent souvent le
roi c'est le roi.
Chafa, c'est ça non ?
Le
c'est Chaolfa, la famille du roi.
Oui, absolument. Oui. Et mais mais
surtout il y avait cette lutte contre le
Marsen, mot qui veut dire aussi magasin,
mais le Marsen c'est l'état profond
marocain. Et et l'état profond marocain
a été très malin, contrairement aux
Algériens qui ont interdit le fils.
Quelques années plus tôt, les Marocains
ont laissé les islamistes s'enfoncer et
se discréditer. Ça a été très malin la
façon dont les Marocains ont géré la
chose.
Revenons à l'Ukraine.
Oui.
On est en quelle année là ? Là, on est
entre euh euh le l'automne 2013 et euh
le début de janvier 2014. La révolution
par envrille, les durs euh donc néonazis
mais aussi nationalistes radicaux euh
suprémacistes ukrainiens ou très très
russophobes euh sont contents que ça
dérape. Pourtant, un accord est trouvé.
Euh Yanukovic accepte de signer un
accord avec l'opposition. Euh on on va
faire des jugements, on va on on va
juger les snipers qu'on va trouver et
cetera. il revient un peu en arrière euh
il il accepte vraiment un deal qu'il
signe avec les deux chefs de
l'opposition et euh ces chef de
l'opposition c'est trop tard, il ça ça
les intéresse pas et il continue à
encourager la révolution et là ça dérape
encore plus violemment et une fois qu'il
y a du sang, c'est difficile de revenir
en arrière parce que des snipers font
des provocations et ensuite le palais
présidentiel est attaqué, le président
Yanukovic doit fuir et en fait c'est un
véritable coup d'état puisque un homme
qui a été élu en 2010 démocratiquement
avec observateurs internationaux doit
fuir son palais présidentiel car il
devient il est menacé physiquement et il
va s'exiler comme on le sait en en
Russie et on va le remplacer par un
président par intérim qui lui est un
atlantiste qui est bien formaté par les
Américains et les Européens de l'Ouest
et ensuite il y aura des élections un
peu plus tard un vendeur de chocolat
oligarque Porochenenko va prendre la
suite va devenir le premier président
ukrainien poste 2013-214 qui va proposer
une entrée à nouveau de l'Ukraine dans
l'OTAN et ensuite plus tard il y aura
Zelenski mais là on est à l'époque de
Porochenenko qui est un qui n'est pas au
départ un nationaliste ukrainien russop
il a fait plein de business tout son
business avec les Russes mais il prend
le vent voilà en route et et il rentre
dans ce nationalisme ukrainien
revanchard antirusse et et il enfonce
son pays dans la guerre puisque
c'est qu'il l' empoisonné lui
alors non celui Celui qui a été
empoisonné, c'était Jovic. C'était
c'était celui qui avait été candidat en
2005 et qui avait été empoisonné aussi
et à nouveau candidat. Et lui, il a
réussi à trouver l'antidote. Il est pas
mort mais il avait le visage défiguré.
C'était le président qui a eu comme
premier ministre Yulia Timoschenko qui
elle était une antirusse au départ. Mais
en fait tout ça c'est du déguisement. On
la présente comme une ukrainienne aux
nates blonde. En fait elle est très
brune. Elle est arménienne et russe.
Elle a pas une goutte de sang ukrainien.
Mais ça c'est de la com. Elle elle elle
on l'a on lui a fait un déguisement.
Mettez-vous avec les nates tressées des
ukrainiennes blondes traditionnelles.
Mais elle est arméo russe comme beaucoup
d'Ukrainiens d'ailleurs. Tout ça est
très mélangé. Mais donc tout ça c'était
de la com. Mais on arrive à Porochenko.
Porochenko en en parlant de l'entrée de
l'OTAN de il relance quelque chose que
la France et l'Allemagne avaient mis un
petit peu de côté et ben le Cassus Belly
revient. Donc réaction, c'est logique.
Si l'Ukraine de Porochenko menace de
rentrer dans l'OTAN, les bases russes
euh militaires euh en Crimé risque
d'être menacé et donc le deal euh d'une
base renouvelable risque d'être caduc.
Donc les Russes, je ne dis pas qu'ils
ont raison. Moi, je suis pas quelqu'un
comme certains dans les milieux
souverainistes qui qui sont en adoration
devant la Russie, mais c'est un fait,
c'est mécanique la géopolitique. La
Russie envahit la Crimée pour en fait
garder un accès aux mer chaudes puisque
la mer la mer noire conduit à la
Méditerranée par les D3 et les Russes se
rappellent de la guerre de 1853 avec
Napoléon I déjà qui avait été entraîné
par les Anglais où déjà il y avait cette
volonté d'empêcher les Russes d'aller
vers le sud. La la la phobie des de de
McKinder avec sa carte du Hartland,
c'est que le Hartland russe accède aux
mers chaudes. Il faut l'encercler par
des cercles concentriques et internes et
externes qui va être repris par
Spikeman, l'américain Spikeman qui lui
va dire c'est le Rimland, il faut
bloquer le Hartland par les côtes de du
continent eurasiatique, le le le Rand.
Donc on est en plein dans la Global
Geopolitics des Anglo-saxons. Et donc
les les Russes sachant cela, euh et bien
au même moment d'ailleurs euh ils
interviennent en Syrie pratiquement au
même moment euh deux endroits où il y a
des bases russes. Les deux bases russes
en Méditerranée, c'était enfin en mer
chaude qui conduisent à la Méditerranée,
c'était la Crimée et la Syrie. Et c'est
2014-25, c'est le grand retour de la
Russie en Méditerranée et dans le monde
arabe parce que elle comprend que après
la Crimée, on va essayer de lui faire
perdre les bases russes en Syrie. Et
voilà pourquoi la la tout tout est lié
en fait en géopolitique. On peut jamais
parler d'un sujet sans parler d'un
autre. Il y a il y a une volonté de la
Russie de se désencercler et de rester
présente dans les mers chaudes qui sont
obsession depuis de siècles. Et
l'obsession de l'OTAN et des
Anglo-saxons depuis de siècles, c'est
priver les Russes de l'accès à la mer
noire et aux mer chaudes. Donc tout ce
tout ce conflit était prévisible. Si on
n'avait pas laissé des revanchards
nationalistes ukrainiens réclamer un
destin atlantique, euh il est très
probable que si cette Ukraine était
restée neutre euh comme malheureusement
c'est le destin des satellites des
grands empires, hein, malheureusement
c'est injuste. Je sais que c'est injuste
moralement, mais un petit pays qui est
proche d'un empire ne peut jamais être
libre. Le Mexique ne pourra jamais avoir
des bases russes ou des bases chinoises
et et le Canada non plus. C'est comme
ça. C'est choquant mais c'est comme ça.
Et donc en en ayant ce fait classique de
la géopolitique, de la stratégie globale
que quand vous êtes un petit état voisin
d'un empire, jamais vous devez tenner
votre terre, votre territoire pour
abriter des armes de l'empire rival. Euh
énormément de de stratèges l'ont dit
Kiss Singer, euh George Kenan euh euh
euh et et et tant d'autres euh
Mirheimer, Kenel Twilz euh et énorme
Stephen Mallz et énormément de stratèges
de l'école réaliste américains
antirusses antisoviétiques qui ont fait
qui ont fait toute la politique de la
guerre froide avait averti donc on a
conduit les Ukrainiens à au charbon en
fait on les a conduit au carnage parce
que ce qu'on leur promettait oui, on va
vous aider à rentrer dans l'OTAN, on va
vous donner des armes, on va vous
entraîner, on va vous on va vous
débarrasser des Russes. C'était
forcément une guerre. Et moi, c'est pas
pour me vanter, j'arrête là, j'étais
trop long. Dans mon premier livre en
1997, au moment où Paul Maricout
écrivait l'Europe vers la guerre,
j'avais déjà annoncé ainsi que dans le
deuxème livre Guerre contre l'Europe en
2000, dans mes deux premiers livres, je
disais attention, si l'OTAN ne sait pas
se freiner comme ça a commencé avec la
guerre en ex-juggoslavie pour empêcher
là aussi les Russes d'accéder aux mer
chaude parce que les Yuggoslaves
venaient de se réconcilier avec les
Russes. Si nous continuons notre marche
vers le vers vers l'est, ça conduira à
une guerre totale avec la Russie. Et si
vous me permettez une toute petite
anecdote. En 99, je vais en Russie avec
le général Henry Paris pour une mission
de reconnaissance. On va voir le Bed, le
fameux Lebed. Vous savez, l'ogre russe
qui était gouverneur de Krasnoyarsk,
héros de transnistrie, grand général,
qui a failli être président.
Lebed ou Lebed ?
Liebed. Voilà. Liebed, Alexandre Liebed
et Libébed nous reçoit
euh déjà Salvabreus nous reçoit, c'est
son bras droit euh taillé spnat assez
impressionnant. Il nous dit "Nous, on
aime les hommes complets physiques et
mentaux. Déjà, on comprend l'atmosphère
et quand on entre dans le bureau de
l'Ebed avec mon général français,
c'était le général rouge, le général
spécialiste de la de la Russie qui
parlait très bien russe et cetera, le
général Lebed nous dit "Faites gaffe
carrément." Il nous parle, on était pas
les amis parce que Lebed avait un
jumelage avec Pasqua, les haut de scène.
Donc il voulait pas trop parler avec
moi, j'étais avec un socialiste, le
général Paris, il était proche du Parti
socialiste et et du gouvernement Jospin
et cetera. Personne n'est parfait, hein.
Personne Personne n'est parfait. Et il
nous a dit "Faites gaffe, c'était le
moment du bombardement de la Serbie.
Vous bombardez nos frères Serbes. Nous
savons très bien pourquoi vous faire ça.
Vous faites ça, c'est pas une mission de
l'OTAN. On vous a les Serbes, vous avez
pas agressé. L'OTAN devient un Otan
expansionniste. Ça finira en guerre
mondiale et en guerre nucléaire. et
pire. Alors là dans l'outrance
typiquement russe, il rajoute "On salira
même avec des terroristes si s'il le
faut, mais on va vous rendre
l'appareil." Donc là, j'ai compris en
1999, voyez, c'est il suffisait de faire
un peu de terrain comme vous aimez le
faire. En allant là, ben j'ai compris
que c'est faux. Quand on nous dit
finalement le problème c'est Poutine.
S'il y avait pas Poutine, ce serait
parfait. Et bien figurez-vous que si le
Bed n'était pas mort d'un accident
d'hélicoptère juste avant que Poutine
devienne président, on aurait eu
quelqu'un peut-être encore plus dur que
lui et plutôt, je pense qu'il aurait été
plutôt lui il aurait pris toute
l'Ukraine en 2016, il l' aurait pas
attendu. Les militaires disaient à
Poutine, prends l'Ukraine dès 2015.
Poutine en fait la preuve qu'il avait
pas un plan d'avance, c'est qu'il a
attendu 2022 parce que justement il il
cherchait un deal Minsk et compagnie.
Euh le B, je pense que lui qui
représentait les militaires hein, les
les les militaires durs, euh on on
beaucoup voulu à Poutine de ne pas avoir
pris l'Ukraine quand elle était faible
en 2015. C'était comme dans Dub. Toute
l'armée ukrainienne était contrôlée par
des Russes. Les services russes
contrôlaient la moitié des généraux ou
plus euh avant que les Américains aident
les Ukrainiens à faire le ménage en
2017, en 2016 disons, euh en 2014-215,
l'Ukraine était facile à envahir pour
les Russes. Donc si Poutine était ce
type qui avait d'emblé l'idée de prendre
toute l'Ukraine, si c'était ça son plan
depuis le début, il l'aurait fait en
2015. Or, il l'a pas fait, il l'a fait
en 2022. D'ailleurs, l'extrême droite
russe ou les militaires russes lui en
veulent. Ils peuvent pas trop le dire
mais ils lui en veulent. Ils disent
"Mais qu'est-ce qu'il a attendu ? Pour
rien c il y aurait eu beaucoup moins de
morts avant."
Là, on est en train de de parler de
l'écume des choses. Oui.
Même avec tout le respect qu'on peut
avoir pour tous les morts qu'il y a eu
sur le terrain, que ce soit du côté
ukrainien, côté russe,
ça reste que l'écume des choses. Là,
j'aimerais qu'on rentre plus dans les
détails, c'estàdire les mouvements de
fonds géopolitique, géostratégique et de
guerre économique.
Oui.
Quel est l'intérêt
de l'Europe à avoir son Nouveau Vietnam
en Ukraine ?
H
Quel est son intérêt ? Son intérêt,
c'est de protéger les enfants, la
démocratie, les écoles pour les petites
filles, la liberté de penser, la liberté
de de faire ce qu'on veut parce que on a
une autodétermination et que c'est le le
le monde occidental et que on est
respecté pour ça. Où est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres choses ? Et s'il y en a s'il y
a d'autres choses autres que tout ce qui
est cosmétique et publicitaire,
quelles sont pour vous les grandes lames
de fond, ce qui bouge les empires ? qui
bouge les puissances et ensuite on on
analysera
la stratégie militaire et stratégique
de l'Europe. Alors
tant sur le côté militaire que
financier,
oui, je pense qu'il faut revenir pour
pour donner des sources accessibles à
nos auditeurs. Revenons à la fameuse
vidéo que vous connaissez sur par cœur
de George Friedman. Le stratège pas
Kenan dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure,
mais le stratège beaucoup plus actuel
qui a créé Stratford qui conseillait le
Pentagone et la CIA. dernier président
de 2015 de Stratford a fait une analyse
très percutante en 2015 à Washington à
Chicago.
Oui. Chicago Institute.
Au Chicago Institute où il
George Friedman a fait cette vidéo en
fait il présentait son livre au Chicago
Institute. C'était une longue vidéo qui
dure plus d'une heure en en en anglais
mais il y a une petite version française
qui s'appelle c'est immoral euh c'est
immoral mais ça marche. C'est cynique,
c'est immoral mais ça marche. Tous les
auditeurs peuvent la retrouver
facilement. C'est un extrait de 11
minutes mais qui est génial. Et
qu'est-ce que dit George Friedman ? Il
dit de
connait les Allemands pas.
Voilà. Absolument. Friedman dit euh tant
que les Allemands ne savent pas où ils
vont aller eux-mêmes et tant que nous
nous ne sommes pas sûr que les Allemands
vont dans la bonne direction,
il y a une énorme inquiétude. On lui
pose une question : "Quelle est la pire
menace pour l'Empire américain ?" Déjà,
il dit "Oui, nous sommes un empire." Là,
il est clair. Il dit "Nous sommes un
empire." Et pour l'empire américain, la
pire chose ce serait que l'Allemagne
aille dans le mauvais vers le mauvais
côté. Si l'Allemagne va vers la Russie,
euh le capital allemand, le savoir-faire
allemand et la masse et l'énergie russe
devient la seule configuration capable
de détrôner l'empire américain. Donc
c'est très intéressant. C'est pas du
narrative prorusse. C'est le plus grand
stratège actuel depuis la mort de
Bjegjinski qui a énormément conseillé
les gens au pouvoir. Donc c'est pas un
type qui a fait des élucubrations dans
une université, il a été au service du
prince. C'est moi je sais d'ailleurs
pratiquement que des gens qui ont été
qui qui ont été en action mais qui ont
pensé comme Geginski a eu deux
doctorats, il a pensé, il a écrit mais
il a été en action. Ceux-là ils sont
intéressants. Et donc il nous dit "On
sait pas ce que va faire l'Allemagne et
et donc si l'Allemagne va vers la
Russie, c'est la seule chose qui menace
l'Empire américain." Au passage, il dit,
on lui pose une question parce que c'est
une conférence, "Est-ce que l'islamisme
est une menace ? Est-ce que la Chine est
une menace ?" Il dit "La Chine, c'est
pas encore une menace au même niveau.
L'islamisme, on peut le traiter assez
facilement. Alors et pour cause, les
Américains l'ont beaucoup utilisé
l'islamisme et en plus il y a l'argent
effectivement des des des pays du golf."
Mais il dit la pire menace pour nous que
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre de
laisser s'incarner, ce serait l'alliance
Allemagne- Russie qui est en fait une
alliance Union européenne Russie. Et je
pense que c'est le fondement, vous
parliez des logiques d'empire, c'est le
véritable fondement de la guerre euh en
Ukraine dont les Européens de l'Ouest
sont les dindons de la phase, je dis
bien de l'Ouest. Car les Polonais
revancharent, les Baltes revancharent,
les Roumains revancharent russophobes. À
la limite, c'est un peu leur guerre.
C'est pas du tout la guerre de la
France. C'est pas la France qui avait
des très bonnes relations avec la
Russie. C'est pas du tout la guerre de
l'Italie. C'est pas la guerre de
l'Espagne, encore moins du Portugal.
C'est une guerre d'Anglo-Saxons qui ont
toujours essayé de couper le russe de
l'ouest de l'Europe, qui ont toujours
essayer d'empêcher la Russie d'accéder
aux mers chaudes. C'est une guerre
anglo-saxonne. Et pourquoi je dis
anglo-saxonne ? Les Américains l'ont
beaucoup favorisé. Mais alors là, ceux
qui ont fait les pires coups, c'est la
fameuse perfie d'Albion. Il y a un
proverbe au Moyen-Orient que vous avez
comme moi à fréquenter qui dit "Quand il
y a un coup fouré, il y a le MI6 quelque
part, il y a les anglais quelque part."
Et il faut avouer qu'ils sont très doués
pour le boxon. Sauf qu'il
maintenant ils ne contrôlent plus leur
propre banlieu et leur propre ville
parce que à force de jouer avec les
islamistes, les anglais ont été les
premiers, ben ils les ont à la maison.
Je me rappelle d'ailleurs d'un d'un
analyste du renseignement, un ancien du
MI6 qui était encore en service mais
dans une structure analytique. J'étais
en stage en Angleterre et il nous a dit
pendant une heure, nous on a accueilli
les pires islamistes. Il me parlait même
du Hizbou Tahrir qui est le mouvement
que vous connaissez probablement. Ce
sont des psychopathes
dire idéologiquement ils sont plus
extrêmes qu'Alqida. et il me disait, ils
sont interdits même par le par par les
mouvements islamistes comme le Hamas à
Gaza. Ils sont interdits en Arabie
Saoudite mais nous on les a accepté à
Londres et il s'est ventait pendant une
heure que Londres avait accepté tous les
pires mouvements islamistes mais il
disait comme ça on les contrôle, on les
connaît puis on peut on peut jouer avec
eux au Moyen-Orient bah maintenant ils
ont un péril à la maison. Ça montre bien
le par rapport à votre question d'avant
la bêtise la bêtise de nos hommes
politiques mais parfois aussi de
certains euh stratège du renseignement
qui en Italie par exemple un je diraiis
pas son nom parce que il est très connu
mais un grand spécialiste du
renseignement italien qui qui fait
beaucoup de médias et qui est informé
par les meilleurs du renseignement
italien me disait "Nous on a aucun
problème avec l'islamisme." Je dis mais
les frères musulmans, le Qatar qui sont
en train de récupérer une partie de
l'immigration musul et même des des
Italiens d'origine immigrés mais italien
qui sont de qui sont musulmans, c'est
quand même du fanatisme, il dit ça c'est
pas grave. Nous, on les l'avantage c'est
que on surveille toutes les mosquées, on
connaît tous les groupes islamistes.
Nous ce qui nous ennuie c'est uniquement
le djihadisme. Je dis mais vous croyez
pas aussi que parfois l'idéologie peut
être une menace si quelqu'un est motivé
à détester le pays où il habite, les
valeurs de ce pays, les institutions de
ce pays, même s'il est pas djihadiste,
c'est une menace ? Il me répond non.
Non, parce qu'au contraire les
islamistes comme les frères musulmans,
c'est les interlocuteurs. Quand on a
besoin de de calmer des gens pour pas
qu'ils deviennent djihadistes, on parle
avec les frères musulmans. Vous voyez ça
? Ça c'est son Laden, c'était aussi un
super interlocuteur pour les États-Unis.
Alors lui c'était carrément un acteur.
Oui. On va on va mettre de côté cette
question qui est très épineuse pour se
focaliser plus sur l'Europe, la Russie,
les phénomènes de guerre économique.
Aujourd'hui George Prima,
aujourd'hui on voit une politique de
réarmement européenne avec les Allemands
qui courent, qui courent, qui court, qui
paniquent, qui paniquent, qui paniquent
et qui vont mettre 1000 milliards sur
les marchés pour s'endetter et se
réarmer. On voit la conscription revenir
un peu partout.
On voit des contrats d'armement sur 25
ans 20 ans avec des des contrats pour
des drones à 5 10 ans. On voit une
Europe courir au réarmement et un
processus diplomatique où ils sont
totalement exclus. Oui.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ils sont en panique
? Et je vous poserai des questions en
fonction de vos réponses.
Oui. Alors, c'est logique. Dans mon
livre, j'ai interrogé quelqu'un que
j'apprécie beaucoup.
Comment votre livre ? euh le nouvel
ordre post-occidental
et j'ai interrogé Olivier Crone.
3 23 €.
Oui, merci. Merci pour la publicité.
Olivier Crone est un grand militaire
officier français qui a été euh dans
beaucoup d'actions très très spéciales
et donc sérieuses et aujourd'hui euh il
a un poste à l'HEDN et c'est c'est un
très très grand connaisseur et il me
disait dans le livre alors que lui est à
fond pour euh se réarmer euh face à une
menace russe hein qui qu'il voit comme
un péril un pays révisionniste lui-même
me disait au maximum on peut envoyer
35000 hommes et le général de Villier
mais aussi d'autres stratèges disaient
ces jours-ci que si on veut se réarmer
soi-disant pour aider les Ukrainiens
contre les Russes, bah il faut faire des
commandes qui vont se concrétiser dans
20 ans. Donc si vous voulez, c'est comme
Zo sans se presser, les le réarmement
européen, il va surtout pas aider les
Ukrainiens à résister au Rus puisque il
va falloir minimum 5 ans pour avoir
assez de assez d'armes conventionnelles
et pour pouvoir avoir un peu plus de
munition que le rien que nous avons
aujourd'hui. et le réalarmement massif
et le passage au 5 % et avant que ça
produise des effets vraiment concrets,
qu'on passe de 200000 hommes, que nous
avons à par exemple 800000 hommes, ça va
mettre 20 ans. Et un exemple, les
Ukrainiens et les Russes tirent chaque
jour plus de drones que la France n'en a
en tout. Et donc pour la guerre en
Libye, je rappelle que au bout de 6
jours, l'Afrique comme le commandement
américain en Afrique et l'OTAN ont mené
toutes les opérations, donc ce
commandement américain parce que les
Anglais et les Français ne pouvaient pas
faire une guerre de haute intensité.
Pourtant, pour bombarder lâchement des
gens de loin sans même de troupe au sol,
hein. On pouvait pas tenir plus de 6
jours. On a même pas d'avion de gros
transporteur. Nous n'avons pas d'avion
suffisamment d'avion ravitailleurs. Nous
n'avons pas de moyens logistiques, nous
n'avons pas de munition. La Russie
produit à elle seule plus de munition
que tous les pays de l'OTAN réunis
Amérique comprise. Et donc voilà
pourquoi on a exclu des négociation
parce que c'est tout ça c'est du c'est
c'est du baratin. C'est même pire que
ça. Le plan des volontaires soi-disant
en fait c'est un plan qui est totalement
cohérent avec le plan Trump. Trump
qu'est-ce qu'il veut ? Il veut nous
déléguer le fardeau. Il veut qu'on paye
les armes américaines mais c'est pas eux
qui les livrent. Donc vous savez que le
celui qui vend une arme il est pas
belligérant. C'est celui qui achète
l'arme et qui va le livrer au béérant
qui lui est belligérant. Donc il est
malin Trump, il nous vend ses armes, on
prend les risques parce que c'est nous
qui les donnons aux Ukrainiens. Donc on
va payer et on va prendre les risques.
Le plan le prend le plan Trump dit aussi
que les Américains ne veulent pas avoir
de contentieux avec les Russes. Ils ne
veulent pas donner des garanties avec
des troupes américaines au sol en
Ukraine. Ça tombe bien, la coalition des
volontaires de Macron et de Starmer et
de et de MERS, ils veulent
prépositionner un jour des troupes
européennes en Ukraine. C'est en fait le
plan de la coalition des volontaires,
c'est envoyer des hommes très peu loin
du front à l'ouest et donner des
garanties avec leur présence militaire
aux Ukrainiens pour nous prendre les
risques et le financement. Et
l'Amérique, elle fait juste de la
reconstruction et elle fait du fric avec
Black Rock. Nous sommes les dindons de
la farce. L'Europe n'a aucun intérêt à
ça et le plan européen de soi-disant
résistance au profit des Ukrainiens
qu'on va aider, c'est du bidon puisque
c'est le plan Trump en vérité, le plan
européen, c'est le plan Trump puisque
nous allons faire exactement ce que
Trump a prévu que nous fassions. Et de
toute façon, les hommes qu'on va
envoyer, c'est après Macron le dit tout
le temps, il est il est il est clair, il
ne m pas. Macron dit "On va envoyer des
hommes peut-être une fois qu'il aura une
solution de paix." Donc je vois pas la
différence entre le plan des volontaires
soi-disant qui sont contre Trump et le
plan Trump. Le plan des volontaires,
c'est exactement ça ce qu'attend de nous
monsieur monsieur Trump qui a comme
théorie géopolitique le offshore
balancing, c'est-à-dire l'équilibrage à
distance, le contraire des démocrates
interventionnistes ou de néoconse. Le
offshore balancing, beaucoup théorisé
par l'école néoréaliste ou réaliste
offensive, c'est à distance. Je je ne
fais je fais le moins de choses
directement. Je délègue le fargau, le
fardeau, le coût et les risques à des
acteurs moyens qui vont être mes vassau
volontaire et en plus je vais leur
laisser croire qu'ils sont devenus euh
les protagonistes fantastiques. Et à
part ça, on nous dit que Trump est
débile.
Donc euh si je vous ai bien compris, les
débiles sont chez nous.
Oui.
Alors pourquoi ils sont débiles ? Est-ce
qu'ils ont pas vu que en terme de guerre
économique, on va se faire lycher parce
que vous connaissez les Russes, vous
l'aurez peut-être pas prononcé le cri
fatidique français parce que vous étiez
peut-être pas en investigation profonde.
Vous connaissez le cri le cri le cri du
français ?
C'est "Si vous arrivez à faire dire
Raoul un russe."
Ah,
vous connaissez Raoul ?
Oui.
Le cri qui d saoule.
D'accord.
Vous connaissez celui-là ? Oui. Alors,
j'ai vu que les Russes tiennent beaucoup
mieux l'alcool que moi, ça c'est clair.
Oui, mais mais parce que vous êtes un
côté espagnol, l'autre côté italien. Il
vous montre le côté bourguignon, c'est
pour ça.
Ah voilà. Si vous êtes bourguignon, je
pense que là vous pouvez tenir.
Ouais. ou alsacien.
Oucienretillois.
Lillois. Ah non, breton, c'est trop
dangereux pour le russe.
On évite de leur envoyer les bretons
parce que en général le Breton tue sa
source.
D'accord.
C'est Oui, le Breton, il y va à fond.
Bon, pour revenir à à notre idée, nous
nous on a les crétins chez nous. On a
les crétins, les excusez-moi
l'expression, mais
les pin d'hîre de la géopolitique, les
pin d'hîre de la guerre économique, les
pinîres de la prévision et de
l'anticipation.
Oui.
Ils ne connaissent pas leur chaîne
logistique, ils ne connaissent pas leur
chaîne énergétique.
Ils ne connaissent pas leurs demandes,
ils ne connaissent pas l'anticipation
pour les trois prochaines années.
Donc là, on se retrouve au milieu
d'Allemands qui vont se retrouver en
concurrence avec les Polonais. Oui,
parce qu'on parle pas beaucoup des
Polonais parce que les Polonais sont en
première ligne, mais quand les Polonais
vont être réarmés, ça va être un autre
c'est autre chose.
Ça va être un autre problème.
Déjà, ils nous ont doublé en nombre
d'hommes 210000 hommes
et ils vont nous doubler en terme de PIB
d'ici 10 ans.
Oui. Ahou ! PIB par tête de PIP, le PIB
polonais d'ici 10 ans est supérieur à
celui du français
en PPA. Non,
par tête de pipe. Ouais.
Oui. Alors, on pas arrêté de pouvoir
d'achat effectivement. Franchement,
exactement. Et donc là, ça va devenir
très compliqué. Donc clair, on se
retrouve nous la France, on va laisser
tomber les Allemands. On sait que
l'Allemand est con. L'Allemand est con
parce qu'il met toujours son verbe à la
fin de la phrase. C'est pour ça qu'il
comprend pas ce qu'on lui demande au
début. Il fait mais il comprend qu'il y
a la fin.
On va on va exclure les Allemands dans
leur leur lecture de géopolitique et
géostratégie parce que eux ils se sont
mis la mouise mais pire que la mise
économie ultra énergivor
dépendant du gaz de chiste américain
dépendant du gaz russe avec des Greta
Tenberg un peu partout des écologistes
un peu partout
je sais pas ce qu'ils vont donner les
Allemands mais les Allemands en terme de
lecture géopolitique ils sont cuits. Ils
sont pas libres en tout cas parce que
l'ancien chancelier ne voulait pas
mettre dans les sanctions le gaz. Et
pour cause, pour que euh Nordstream 1 et
2 soit accepté, parce qu'il y avait
plein de règles, vous savez, le le
distributeur doit pas être même que le
producteur, euh les Allemands ont
investi. En fait, c'était un projet qui
était pas que russe, c'était aussi des
capitaux allemands et euh et et donc les
Allemands ne voulaient pas mais ils ont
été contraints. En fait, c'est c'est un
pays qui n'est pas libre. Donc débile,
c'est pas une insulte parce que en
latin, c'est faible. Et en voilà, débile
en espagnol, ça veut dire qu' est
faible. L'avantage de de discuter avec
les italiens, c'est que il sait ce que
ça veut dire formidable.
Oui.
Donc revenons revenons à notre stratégie
de guerre économique. Nous, on est
français, on a quand même des grands
penseurs, on a quand même des grands
stratèges de guerre.
Et comment ça se fait qu'on ait Bruno
Lumè qui nous dit "Bon, on va mettre
l'économie à genou". Alors ça
quand on a entendu Brer, on s'est dit
euh les antidépresseurs ils sont très
forts.
Alors j'adore ça parce que pour écrire
mon livre, j'ai voulu quand même aller
un minimum. J'ai pas pu aller partout,
on peut pas aller à la fois en Ukraine
et en Russie, mais j'ai j'ai au moins pu
aller 8 jours enquêter auprès des
patrons français. Donc je précise he
j'ai pas été lécher les bottes des des
des Russes. J'ai été voir des patrons
français de la chambre de commerce
française. J'ai vu aussi le centre
culturel français mais j'ai j'ai fait
des malles. J'ai visité des fermes, des
usines avec des patrons français et tout
tout ce qu'ils m'ont dit c'est que ils
n'ont pas envie de revenir en France.
Ils m'ont dit et tous hein et c'était
pas des mutuelles spéciales. Ils m'ont
dit avec une mutuelle normale de
n'importe quelle russe, ils m'ont dit
c'est difficilement audible chez nous.
Notre système de santé est bien plus
performant que le système français. Tous
ces patrons que j'ai rencontré, une
trentaine, ils m'ont dit "Nous, on est
français mais quand on va en vacances en
France, on prie pour ne pas être malade
en France. On prie que si on a un jour
un gros pépin, on prie pour que ça
arrive en Russie." Euh le pétrole et le
gaz, on peut en parler aussi. J'ai
interrogé quatre traders pour mon livre.
Indien, russe, anglais, anglo qui
anglais qui travaille pour Reliance, la
plus grosse raffinerie indienne aussi
espagnole. Et j'ai voulu comparer, ils
m'ont tous dit "C'est une immense
fumisterie, tout le monde achète du gaz
et du pétrole russe par plein de voies."
Mais ce qui est pas connu, c'est que le
gaz n'a jamais été sous sanction. Le gaz
russe a été saboté. Le gaz russe pas
cher et écologique par gaz auc. Il a été
saboté par l'opération terroriste
Nordstream 1 et 2 qui est une opération
terroriste illégale puisque'en plus il y
avait des capitaux allemands, c'est
aussi contre contre les Allemands. Mais
le gaz russe euh qu'on appelle GNL, euh
donc liquéfié par bateau qui lui a un
prix plus élevé, c'est les prix spot.
Bizarrement, il a augmenté de 43 % pour
la France et plusieurs pays européens.
Après la guerre, il y a eu plus de gaz
russes par bateau légalement, je ne
parle pas de de tout ce qui est faux,
tout ce qui est masqué légalement
importé. On a augmenté plus de gaz
russes par bateau. C'était justement
l'ambition de Gazprom de faire pas que
du gaz auc mais aussi du gaz par bateau
parce qu'il est il a des prix plus
élevés. Et pourquoi les Américains l'ont
permis alors qu'ils ont saboté des gaz
auuc ? Parce que le gaz auoduc c'était
40 % moins cher.
Pourquoi les Américains on c'est les
Américains qui ont saboté pour vous ?
Bien sûr, c'est un commando. C'est un
commando.
C'est quoi vos sources ? Alors mes
sources alors vous avez raison, on n pas
de certitude en géopolitique mais en
parlant avec un certain nombre d'experts
ou de spécialistes de l'énergie, on sait
une chose là de manière certaine ou
c'est des bruits de couloir.
Oui. Non non je vais je vais en venir.
Je vais en venir. Non c'est des Polonais
et des Ukrainiens dont on connaît les
noms. Le l'avant-dernier avait été
arrêté en Italie cet été. Mais euh dans
la mesure où il y avait une opération
des forces de l'OTAN avec des forces
spéciales anglaises, danoises et
américaines au à l'endroit même où il y
a eu euh l'explosion, si vous voulez, il
y a quand même de très grandes chances
que ça a été soit une cover action de la
CIA déléguée à des Ukrainiens ou des
Polonais, soit que ou ou soit une
implication du MI6, soit en tout cas une
autorisation, une accointance. Mais ce
que l'on peut affirmer, vous avez
raison, ça c'est pas sûr. C'est une
hype. C'est une hypothèse pour l'instant
pour pour moi c'est pas fumé. C'est très
probable. Pas parlé de l'avion américain
qui aurait pu balancer une bou
Oui, avec le sonard. Oui, oui, oui,
aussi il y a il y a
on entend beaucoup de conneries autour
de ça. Non,
il y a beaucoup de conneries. Y a il y a
il y a la J'en parle de mon livre, il y
a il y a Smour Erche avec son enquête.
Il y a aussi l'enquête bah du tribunal
allemand. Le tribunal allemand ne dit
pas la CIA, mais le tribunal allemand en
tout cas a démantelé les noms.
Maintenant, on connaît les noms du
commando qui était en tout cas un
commando. Ce qui est certain, c'est que
c'était pas les Russes. Au début, on a
dit c'est les Russes qui font ça pour
justifier voilà, on l' fait à l'envers,
voilà ou voilà ou pour nous le font à
l'envers pour ensuite accuser les
autres. On sait aujourd'hui que c'est le
camp procidental antirusse. Ça c'est ça
c'est une certitude puisque il y a même
une enquête allemande et même la Pologne
a refusé d'extrader un des un des un des
chefs de commando en disant ben pour
nous euh il a fait une bonne action.
Donc aujourd'hui il y a même des aveux.
Par contre effectivement vous avez
raison, on ne peut pas affirmer ce que
la CIA l' fait mais disons que
énormément de personnes
du renseignement ou ancien du
renseignement ou militaire ou tout
simplement géopolitologue stratège qui
suis ou énergéticien. Moi en tout cas
m'ont dit que c'est très probable. Mais
vous avez raison, ce n'est pas une
certitude.
Par exemple, moi on m'a dit que l'Irak
avait des armes de destruction massive
et qu'il y avait 95 % de la communauté
du renseignement qui était d'accord pour
nous dire ça.
Alors les destructions alors c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
le rapport Blix en 1995
avait prouvé
Blitz qui était un un monsieur qui était
censé visiter les infrastructures
absolument
et qui est revenu en disant il y a il y
a rien.
Il avait dit il y a rien
et il s'est fait taper dessus à gogo. il
s'est fait taper dessus. Or, le gaz
sarin des iraquiens était expiré parce
que le gaz sarin, il a il a il a une
expiration. Il il vit pas éternellement
à un moment, il il est plus il est plus
actif. Le biologique, il ne le
maîtrisait pas parce qu'il y a trois
hein euh chimique, voilà, biologique et
le nucléaire, il y avait une
renonciation totale du nucléaire par
l'Irak parce que de toute façon, les
Israéliens s'étaient occupés de
bombarder avec d'ailleurs la complicité
des Français qui avaient équipé l'Irak.
Nous, on a équipé l'Irak, mais on a aidé
les Israéliens à bombarder les
équipements que nous avions livrés, y
compris et même à faire assassiner un
certain nombre de scientifiques sur le
sol français. Donc l'Irak avait renoncé
euh à deux euh armes de destruction
irraquien, c'est ça ?
Des des scientifiques iraakiens et
égyptiens. Oui. des des scientifiques
iraakiens et égyptiens qui travaillaient
pour le programme nucléaire iraakien
avait été tué par le groupe Aman. C'est
un service d'élimination qui est en fait
concurrent, enfin pas concurrent mais
qui est complémentaire du Mossade parce
que les gens parlent tout le temps du
Mossade, mais souvent c'est Aman et euh
et je dis pas que c'est bien au mal
attention hein, mais je je dis juste que
c'était les accidents malons.
C'était les accidents. Non mais mais
quelque part je comprends les services
les services de renseignement des pays
qui sont puissants ou qui sont dans une
logique de survie doivent utiliser même
Hollande, on en parlait tout à l'heure,
Hollande est l'homme qui le fait le plus
il a fait le plus exécuté de djihadistes
en Syrie. Et donc c'est c'est normal les
les on n'est pas là pour juger he c'est
froid la géopolitique. Un état digne de
ce nom qui est assez puissant, il
élimine des gens régulièrement. C'est
tout à fait Je dis pas que c'est bien,
c'est normal. C'est enfin normal au sens
c'est la normalité.
Revenons. Revenons à la la guerre
économique en Europe. Notre cécité.
Alors là ça va faire 5 ans combien de
temps c'est ça va faire 3 4 ans la
guerre en Ukraine, c'est ça ?
Oui. Oui. Février 2022.
nos grands stratèges de guerre
économique, les fameux qui nous ont
réindustrialisé,
fait un grand plan de
réindustrialisation.
Là, ils font la cavalerie, ils ont
toujours pas compris où ils servent des
intérêts qui sont pas les nôtres ou ou
ils sont un peu crétins.
Là, je vous retourne la chose. Comment
vous pouvez prouver ça ? Mais je pense
comme vous. Il ser pas les je pose des
questions.
Oui. Oui. Alors je
Oui, mais il sert pas les intérêts qui
sont les infini quand on regarde notre
balance commerciale, notre
désindustrialisation et même si le
conflit se fige avec des accords de
paix, c'est si la ligne de front seig et
que ça il y a moins il y a que des
petites escarmouches. Vous connaissez
les Russes
h
ils tuent pas leur chien quand ils mort.
Il leur arrache toutes les dents parce
que ça peut continuer d'aboyer. Ça peut
être intéressant.
Là, en terme de guerre économique, ils
vont nous arracher toutes les dents.
C'est que là, ils vont s'arrêter. Est-ce
que
c'est
vous dites il les américain ou les
Russes ? Ah oui, les Russes, c'est
intéressant. Est-ce que les Allemands,
les Français et les Anglais qui viennent
de se reconnecter à la réalité ont
compris que le russe, il est quand même
un peu rancunier ? Père, il risque de
nous arracher toutes les dents derrière
son rideau de fer parce que cette
fois-ci, c'est lui qui veul mettre le
rideau de fer.
Pourquoi on a toujours pas compris ça ?
Sa façon de nous arracher les dents
comme les forts, c'est de s'entendre
avec un autre fort par mépris du faible.
C'est ça qui nous arrive. Donc débile au
sens faible en étymologie. Et là, ils
vont s'entendre avec les les Américains
déjà à Encore, il avait été décidé même
avant Encoredge que Exon retourne en
Russie. Le décret a été signé par
Poutine pour le retour de Hexon, donc
pour nos auditeurs, une grande société
américaine d'hydrocarbure. Le les les
les
ressources en gaz de nord de la Russie
près de l'Arctique vont être valorisé
par un plan américain. Black Rock est
dans est dans l'histoire, mais aussi
toutes les sociétés pétrolières et et
gazières américaines sont très
intéressées et aussi total en France par
des ressources énergétiques russes que
les Russes peuvent pas se permettre de
tous valoriser parce que c'est des
investissements énormes. L'énergie, le
pétrole et le gaz, c'est énorme et
surtout quand c'est dans des zones
extrêmement hostiles. Et donc les Russes
ont besoin de valoriser tout cela avec
des investissements extérieurs. qui a un
deal qui est en train de se faire des
grandes boîtes américaines de pétrole et
et et les et les boîtes privées où
public russes vont s'entendre sont en
train de s'entendre pour valoriser des
immenses ressources de gaz et de pétrole
parce que ce que ce que nos auditeurs
doivent savoir c'est que le gaz est une
énergie de transition surtout le gaz par
gaz auc la moins polluante c'est la
moins émrice de CO2 des trois énergies
fossiles. Donc le gaz encore beaucoup
d'avenir même si nous on prétend que
l'Europe morale Green Deal Repower
Europe tous les tous les violon sur une
Europe décarbonisée bullshit on est au
charbon maintenant en Allemagne.
Carboné parce que carbonisé on risque de
le pendant on est Oui, on est décarboné
merci pour ce lapsus. On est décarboné
mais avec le charbon ça qui est
extraordinaire. On a une Europe en train
de se décarboner mais la Pologne
l'Allemagne retourne au charbon. Et donc
nous sommes encore le cocu de
l'histoire. On on s'est interdit
d'ailleurs le gaz de chiste en France he
on s'est interdit la production de gaz
de chiste.
Bon, on a mal, on commence à avoir mal.
Là, je regardais ce matin la carte
publie par les échos des sites français
en train de se fermer ou
désindustrialiser. Ça ressemblait à une
carte de bombardement
depuis depuis 10000 m d'altitude comme
si on s'était pris une
comment on appelle ça ? grap de bombe
sur nos sites industriels.
Revenons, revenons à la guerre
économique. Nos stratèges, nos
dirigeants, nos analystees et nos péons
sur le terrain.
Là, quand on tire les courbes,
oui,
on va dans le mur. Bon, la France en
premier
mais là, on n pas écouté les stratèges.
Non mais les stratèges euh je veux bien
ils ont fait une grve de la fin, ils ont
fait quelque chose, ils sont partis dans
le privé.
Les disons les les les grands stratèges
des grands groupes comme Total ou autres
et beaucoup de géopolitologues euh
n'étaient pas pour ces sanctions qui
sont absolument euh inefficaces. Mais
c'est comme la guerre en Libye avec
Sarkozy quand quand il y a l'Occident,
c'est que de la com. L'Occident est
devenu une coquille vide qui n'est m que
par la com. C'est la société du
spectacle. Et donc nos dirigeants
n'écoutent pas les les les grands chefs
d'entreprise. Par exemple, le chancelier
allemand n'a pas écouté tous ces grands
industriel qui lui disaient "Nous, si
l'énergie est quatre cinq fois plus
cher, on va se casser aux États-Unis et
où on va être ruiné." Il y a des
boulangeries qui ferment tous les 5
minutes en France. J'étais avec des
patrons là du patronat français
récemment. Il me disaient "C'est une
catastrophe, on a des commandes qui
baissent et plein de boîtes qui
ferment." On le sait très bien. Nos
hommes politiques le savaient. Mais la
com est plus importante que tout. Il
fallait être dans le vent. Rappelez-vous
madame Van Derleyen, elle a mis les
costumes au aux couleurs de de
l'Ukraine. On a Macron à un moment qui
était mal rasé et qui était en t-shirt
noir pour avoir l'air un peu zelenskien.
Si vous voulez tout ça, c'est de la com
et donc l'intérêt l'intérêt national
comme je disais tout à l'heure a disparu
depuis 40 ans en France hein. Il a ça
fait depuis 40 ans qu' personne n'a le
sens de l'intérêt national à la tête de
l'État y compris ceux que j'ai un moment
servi ou pour qui j'ai j'ai voulu rouler
un petit peu et je regrette beaucoup de
l'avoir fait. Et donc c'est pas étonnant
comme ils sont que dans la com, il faut
avoir l'air alors pendant les
révolutions arabes, il fallait avoir
l'air euh pour le démantellement des
régimes arabes euh militaires, laïcar
euh cadafistes ou euh bacharistes et
cetera. Alors, on avait fait une
alliance avec eux 2 ans plus tôt et tout
à coup, on les bombarde. On est passé
euh de l'accueil de Bachar Al-Assad aux
Champs-Élysées au bombardement de son
régime sans transition par pas au
bombardement mais euh Kaddafi et euh et
Bachar, on est passé de son accueil à
euh financer des des des djihadistes
pour le faire tomber. Et effectivement,
Cadfi, on est passé carrément de
l'accueil à Matignon à bombardement en
détournant une une résolution des
Nations-Unies. Mais parce que c'est là
comme on était grillé, la France était
proche des quatre pays arabes qui ont
été les premières cibles du printemps
arabe. Et le printemps arabe,
rappelez-vous, c'était euh des jeunes
imberes euh laïques, occidentalistes qui
nous aiment beaucoup. Comme mon ami Lina
Ben Mini, c'était une moderniste avec un
piercing euh très sincère d'ailleurs
hein. Je je dis pas j'ai pas de mépris
pour elle. Je lui disais attention, tu
as déclenché la révolution du Jasmin.
Lina Benis, c'est elle qui a qui a lancé
ce ce truc. Tu as pas peur de faire
venir les islamistes au pouvoir ? Non.
Non, on prend ce risque. Mais la société
par de quoi ? De Enarda ?
Euh non, voilà, Enarda, elle le elle
disait il y a un risque qu'ils arrivent
au pouvoir, mais nous on pense vraiment
que que que la société arabe est mure.
Il y a pas de malédiction pour la
démocratie. C'est nous qui allons
gagner. Et les islamistes on ont on ont
on ont pris le dessus. Revenons de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée.
Là l'économie française allemande qu'à
94 % des industries allemandes énergé
énergivor qui ont épuisé toutes leurs
solutions et ils sont en train d'émettre
l'hypothèse de l'hypothèse de son allié.
Oui. Aux États-Unis notamment.
Oui. C'est pas cher làbas.
Quatre fois moins cher
donc il va nous rester quoi en Europe ?
Parce que si on doit reconstruire, si on
doit reconstruire nous la France, on a
plus rien. Non,
je pense qu'on va devenir une zone de
vilégiature.
Ouais. Non, ça c'est pas sûr encore.
Notre premier ministre, ministre des
affaires étrangères et notre président
de la République nous ont pas beaucoup
aidé à l'extérieur. L'image du français
ou du gouvernement français ou de la
France à l'extérieur s'est dégradé
en grande partie grâce à eux.
La dressons le cap.
entre chefs d'entreprise. Oui.
Ceux qui font tourner le pays en fin de
compte. Ah,
ils sont désemparés. Moi, je je les
rencontre souvent.
Nous aussi, on les rencontre et ils
viennent nous pleurer sur les poules
pour nous dire il faut que bon
là, on fait on fait la trajectoire de
l'Europe. Notre dette éclate.
Oui.
Notre consommation énergétique baisse
mais on paye plus cher. On est dans une
récession de dingue. On va en signer. On
va en prendre pour combien de temps ?
parce que quand l'industrie de la belle
parlotte des des présidents B2 aura fini
euh le petit sort, les
c'est ce côté joyeux de lunettes rose où
euh on on invoque X ou Y sentiment chez
l'autre quand ça va s'effondrer parce
que les frigos seront vides et qu'on se
chauffera à 13°gr et que on en aura un
peu marre de beaucoup de choses, il va
nous rester quoi ? Quelle est la
trajectoire de la France de l'Europe ?
On va sur un climat de guerre civile, on
va sur un climat de guerre tout court
avec les Russes pour quand même essayer
de graper d'agrapiller quelque chose.
Alors, la guerre avec les Russes, je n'y
crois pas tout de suite parce qu'on
n'est pas prêt dans mon
eux ils sont prêts.
Eux, ils sont Alors, ils sont très
prêts. Moi, je me rappelle en 2012, je
suis avec une délégation euh
dans quel cadre ? dans le cadre de euh
dirigeants de parti de centre-Doit de
cinq pays européens, mais je peux pas
dire les noms parce que c'était les gens
très connus et euh et et nous
officiel ça
non officieux
si c'est officieux on en parle pas
on en parle pas alors en tout cas je me
rappelle qu'en 2012 moi, admettons que
j'y sois allé tout seul, on m'a fait
visiter des abris nucléaires 2012, donc
c'était avant
ça où ça ?
À Moscou.
Ah oui
et à Saint-Pétersbourg. Et et on nous a
dit nous sommes prêts à une guerre
nucléaire totale avec l'Occident. Et
c'était 2 ans avant la guerre de Crimé.
Et là, j'ai senti qu'il y avait un truc
assez chaud. Et on avait rencontré à
l'occasion le confesseur de Poutine, le
fameux père Tyron qui est très célèbre,
très célèbre. Il écrit des livres à des
millions d'exemplaires. Il est plus
important que le patriarche Kyril. C'est
lui qui souffle à l'oreille des grands
décideurs et ça fait bien dans la Russie
3e Rome néoorthodoxe de de le
fréquenter. Lui, il nous a présenter
l'Europe comme un continent euh
satanique et un continent de
la décadence absolue. Et j'ai senti donc
2 ans avant la guerre en Crimée que euh
ça allait un jour mal finir avec les
Russes. ce que je disais déjà depuis les
années fin des années 90, j'ai senti que
il y avait un énorme problème, un énorme
contentieux et c'est pas étonnant que ça
soit ça c'était 2013 pardon et c'était 1
an après 2012 la fameuse tentative
occidentale de faire une révolution de
velour en Russie, la fameuse révolution
blanche ou révolution des neiges où
Indovment for Democracy toutes ces
associations qui ont fait qui ont
déstabilisé l'Ukraine ont essayé de
faire pareil en Russie et là je dis pas
que c'est bien et mal hein peut-être
c'est très sincère ceux qui ont voulu
voulu faire ça. Il voulait vraiment la
démocratie hein, on peut pas adopter.
Mais euh ça a complètement là rendu pas
hystérique mais ça a rendu
définitivement hostile la Russie parce
qu'elle s'est dit ils veulent nous faire
tomber.
Quelle est ma question ?
Oui,
c'était quoi ma question ?
J'ai oublié.
OK, je la repouse dernière fois.
La trajectoire que vous anticipez pour
la France et pour l'Europe.
Oui.
économiquement, socialement et
militairement.
Moi je pense que socialement en France,
on va arriver dans le schéma
intéressant, enfin horriblement
intéressant d'une victoire probable du
Front National Bardella ou Marine Le Pen
qui va déclencher un prétexte pour une
révolte sociale et qui n'est pas sûr de
réussir mais une partie de l'extrême
gauche va appeler à une révolution mais
je ne suis pas sûr que les banlieux
suivent mais peut-être que oui,
peut-être que non. une une
déstabilisation quand même assez forte
au niveau économique. Euh
un genre de révolution de couleur chez
nous ?
Euh non, un peu différent. Une
révolution du Grand soir ou les forces
les forces euh comment dirais-je euh les
forces révolutionnaires qui qui ont pour
but de déstabiliser euh parce que le le
but d'un trosquiste, c'est c'est un but
de révolution permanente hein. Et c'est
pas pour l'accuser. Moi j'ai connu les
trosquis qui me disaient on veut la
révolution permanente et cetera. Et donc
ils vont essayer d'utiliser ce prétexte
de du fascisme qui arrive au pouvoir
pour déclencher une révolution. Donc il
peut y avoir des troubles, pas une
guerre civile comme en parle Zemour,
mais des troubles dans pas mal de points
de France compliqués à gérer avec des
méthodes démocratiques actuelles
libérales parce qu'on peut être
démocratique illibéral mais avec les
méthodes actuelles. Et du point de vue
économique, je pense que l'Europe elle
se elle se dirige. Je vois comment est
Rome, je vois comment sont certaines
villes en Italie déjà. Il y a une sorte
de village villégiaturisation de
l'Europe. Nous nous sommes
désindustrialisés et on risque pas de se
réindustrialiser puisque aujourd'hui le
plan Green Deal et le et le Repower
Europe hein de de madame Van Derleyen de
la Commission européenne veut interdire
d'ici 2035. Alors, il paraît que ça va
être retardé, mais on veut interdire
tous les moteurs à à fossil à
combustible, bah ça va relancer
l'économie chinoise, l'industrie
chinoise. On va être inondé de voitures
chinoises. Certes, on peut me répondre
mais si on met des taxes énormes, on
pourra empêcher la venue sur le marché
de de produits chinois. Mais eux, le
protectionnisme, bah, ils vont ils vont
rendre l'appareil. Donc ça va être très
compliqué de d'empêcher totalement
l'inondation et donc de de produits
chinois. Donc je pense que les
industries automobiles européennes vont
être complètement déclassées puisque les
les les Chinois, vous parlez de supply
chain tout à l'heure de chaîne
d'approvisnement, il contrôlent 90 % de
la chaîne d'approvisionnement de la
production au raffinage jusqu'à à la
vente entre eux, l'Indonésie et
l'Afrique. Ils ont pris le contrôle de
80 à 90 % des terreurs rares et des
métaux précieux, y compris aluminium,
nickel et cetera. Euh, ils ont bien sûr
le monopole des batteries, les monopoles
du photovoltaïque. Ils sont bons en
nucléaire, en torium nucléaire, donc le
le le nucléaire le moins impolluant. Ils
sont bons en nucléaire classique, ils
sont bons en photovoltaïque, ils sont
bons en renouvelable et et ils sont de
mieux en mieux en hydrocarbure puisque
ils vont avoir avec les Russes force de
Sibérie 1 et 2. Donc si vous voulez,
l'Europe euh va euh tomber dans un euh
une popérisation et c'est ce que j'ai
appelé le symbole le syndrome de
l'argentinisation de la France et de
l'Europe. Nous allons connaître une
argentinisation, c'est pas certain hein,
j'ai aucune certitude, mais c'est
vraiment extrêmement probable que nous
soyons de plus en plus paupérisés. Moi,
je vois par exemple l'Italie et je
reviendrai sur la France. J'ai vu, je
vais en Italie depuis 30 ans parce que
j'ai double carrière un petit peu des
d'écrivains là-bas aussi, beaucoup de
conférences, de réunions et la baisse du
niveau de vie d'un italien moyen est
absolument stupéfiante mais stupéfiante.
Et en France, quand on voit que des des
des ouvriers agricoles, des fermiers
peuvent avoir une retraite de de 600 €
vous imaginez ce que c'est pour survivre
et et et avec un SMIC aujourd'hui, il
est normalement impossible de faire
vivre une famille. Donc c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement terrifiant.
L'énergie l'énergie nous coûte quatre à
cin fois plus cher. Et l'idée de l'IEL,
l'ordre international libéral, c'est de
couper durablement, pas maintenant,
durablement l'Europe de la Russie et
donc de l'énergie la moins chère. Or,
l'énergie, c'est tout. dans dans
l'économie, si l'énergie est trop chère,
euh il y a pas que les boîtes
automobiles, les boulangers euh peuvent
pas font faillite, l'énergie euh est
absolument fondamentale. Donc il y a une
il y a une paupérisation pour une autre
raison aussi. Euh l'économie nouvelle va
être de plus en plus euh va avoir besoin
de gens qui sont bons en technologie,
qui sont des bons scientifiques, des
bons des des des bons informaticiens,
des bons codeurs et cetera. Et nous
sommes passés de 1 en un siècle à 27e en
mathématiques. Euh je connaissais une
amie qui est de Singapour me disait que
sa fille a a eu deux classes d'avance.
Elle était encore la première quand elle
est arrivée de Singapour. En en sautant
deux classes de suite, elle est restée
encore la première. Elle a été convoquée
sa maman parce que ça ça troublé le
français qui qui était un peu
déstabilisé par cette extrême
compétence. Ça c'est le déclassement
aussi technologique et scientifique.
C'est-à-dire que on n'est même pas sûr
de pouvoir suivre la nouvelle économie
digitale. Déjà on n pas les matières
premières, on n pas les terreurs rares,
on n pas les batteries et cetera. Mais
mais en plus on on n'est même pas sûr
d'avoir moi je vois mes élèves par
exemple, ils ne peuvent pas suivre un
cours plus de 10 minutes sans que je
dois faire un petit peu de rigolade de
un peu de sketch. Je fais un peu du gars
almané géopolitique pour tirer leur
attention parce qu'il ils ne peuvent pas
être attentés. Si George Carline, c'est
mieux que Gadel Mané.
Voilà. Oui, si vous voulez. Moi, j'aime
bien
Elmané parce qu'il est en train de se
convertir au christianisme. Il a il est
très très courageux parce que c'est
c'est quand même assez audacieux. Mais
non, à Bagapard, moi je vois la le
manque d'attention à part quelques
grandes écoles d'élite, le niveau de
l'enseignement est devenu absolument
pitoyable. Un autre exemple, dans mon
ancienne école de commerce à La
Rochelle, un Indonésien était venu,
parlait pas français. En 1 an, il était
major et en 2 ans, il faisait du soutien
scolaire pour les Français de souche euh
juste d'une promo en dessous pour vous.
Et là, là, j'ai compris le monde
multipolaire et j'ai compris que c'est
une forme de racisme ou de mépris. On on
a délocalisé partout, on a
désindustrialisé en se disant "Ça
restera des ploues. Tous ces gens des
pays du sud, ils vont produire pour
nous. On a une économie d'échelle, on a
des on a une grande rentabilité. Euh, on
s'est totalement détruit,
désindustrialisé, mais eux, ils se sont
cultivés, même s'ils ont plein de
d'analphabètes, ils ont plus
d'alphabétisés que nous, plus de tésards
que nous, plus de plus d'ingénieurs
énormément même la Russie a plus
d'ingénieurs que nous. Donc, on est
déclassé technologiquement mais aussi
intellectuellement. Donc, nous allons
nous popériser dans tous les sens du
terme parce que nous n'urons même plus
les cadres. Ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir un revenu universel pour abruti.
Je je sais que j'exagère, c'est un peu
un jeu de style pour attirer
l'attention, mais c'est assez effrayant.
C'est assez effrayant. Moi, je vois mes
étudiants turcs, mes étudiants
tunisiens, mes étudiants indonésiens, je
les trouve il ils ont plus ils ont plus
la hargne, l'envie de réussir. Ils ont
plus le sens de l'effort. Mais
asiatiques sont carrément disciplinés.
Mes étudiants français n'ont ni
discipline, ni sens de l'effort, ni
culture générale. Il y a un
abrutissement
débile au sens faible, mais aussi au
sens abruti. Il y a une débilitation
totale de de la société occidentale qui
est structurelle, qui est liée à à la
société du spectacle, de la
consommation, de l'édonisme, du plaisir,
du désir. Parce qu'en fait la société
capitaliste occidentale, elle est fondée
sur le désir permanent et créer de
nouveaux désirs pour de nouvelles
consommations. Donc on fait des gens
addicts. Les produits d'origine
américaine, c'est les Américains qui ont
lancé ça en premier. C'est des produits
qui vous droguent. Une série, elle est
faite pour vous droguer. Un sandwich, il
est fait pour vous droguer. Le
Coca-Cola, c'est une drogue. En fait,
que ça soit des produits,
le sucre,
le sucre, le sel et et le gras. Alors,
c'est ce qu'il y a de pire. On a fait
des tests sur les
la drogue des pauvres, ils appellent ça
comme ça en Argentine. Revenons à
l'Argentine.
Oui. L'argentinisation de la France et
de l'Europe.
Euh, on a une monnaie qui s'appelle
l'euro.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en Argentine
avec le PCOS argentin ? Ah ben je me
rappelle en 2000, il y avait la il y a
il y avait la dollarisation euh qui
avait été voulue par les les pseudos
libéraux libérau-opéroniste à l'époque
mais euh l'Argentine ne s'est jamais
remis de la crise de 2000 2001 et euh et
ensuite on a eu euh toute cette
alternance néopéroniste qui a encore
aggravé la situation et aujourd'hui
alors là je suis pas forcément pour ce
candidat au départ mais Miley Miley est
en train de de sevrer les argentins qui
ont
à grandfort de de dollars
à grand fort de dollars et aussi de de
de d'économistes riganiens néo enfin pas
néoconservateurs mais libéraux
conservateurs.
Alors oui alors pour parler de
l'Argentine ou
Ouais. Non mais l'Argentine c'est la
zone d'influence américaine où ils
veulent se on va on va revenir sur la
zone d'influence américaine.
D'accord. En gros, il est en train de de
de de dégraisser le mammouth et je pense
que c'est pas forcément mauvais pour
l'Argentine. L'Argentine a été trop dans
le dans l'étatisme. L'Europe
l'Europe, on a on fait beaucoup de bruit
avec notre bouche. C'est la la société
de l'événementiel de la com.
Oui, de la com.
On a pas de matière première. On a
Et on s'est interdit aussi. Ouais,
on a Oui, on s'est interdit parce que
le torium, on l'avait dans les années
60, on l'a abandonné. C'était le
meilleur nucléaire et on s
et on s et aussi l'autre forme de
nucléaire santorium. Et bien sûr les
hydrocarbures, on s'est interdit le
Je voudrais qu'on fasse un constat en
fait pour nos copains français européens
qui nous regardent, on les embrasse
d'ailleurs, on leur dit de nous soutenir
sur Tipi parce qu'on a besoin d'eux que
ça nous permet d'être indépendant et de
prendre le temps.
Là en Europe, on a peur. Nous en tant
que stratège, on se dit là le bateau il
coule beaucoup. On les voit s'agiter,
faire des des bruits avec leurs bouches
et faire des grands gestes avec leurs
bras.
en terme dans le dur, dans l'industrie,
pas d'énergie, pas de matière première,
une monnaie fantôme basée sur du bla bla
bla bla bla, le conflit en Ukraine qui a
pas l'air de tourner à notre avantage et
surtout les conséquences d'une
géopolitique de demeurer. Les Russes
vont nous le faire payer soit par la
guerre,
soit par la guerre économique. Vous
connaissez le principe de guerre
économique ? un chômeur coûte plus cher
qu'un mort
en tant que stratège adverse l'objectif
c'est pas de faire des morts, c'est de
faire des chômeurs.
Donc là, si vous étiez premier ministre
ou président ou ce que vous voulez avec
un poste important en France,
vous leur donnez quoi qu'on conseille à
ceux qui sont en train de planter notre
pays pour les 50 ou 100 prochaines
années ? Alors, deux conseils.
Faire la politique de la chaise vide à
l'Union européenne lors des Conseils
pour exiger
la possibilité
d'importer du gaz russe par gaz au
supprimer des sanctions les énergies et
alors qu'en 2027 la commission a pour
plan de de se lester définitivement du
gaz et du pétrole
13 ou 12 % de reste. Ouai. Ouais. En
fait, c'est un peu plus si on compte le
euh pour certains pays, c'est 40 %, pour
d'autres c'est 10 effectivement.
Les Hongrois, on s'en fout. Les
Hongrois,
oui, oui.
C'est les Hongrois, ils sont à combien
de pourcent les Hongrois ?
Les Hongrois, je pense que là c'est du
euh pas 80 %. Bah, les Hongrois, ils ont
ils ont obtenu une exception
les conseils les conseils pour euh nos
grands stratéges là.
Voilà. donc rétablir la possibilité d'
d'importer du gaz russe et donc
œuvrer à la réparation de de Nordstream
1 et 2. Mais encore faut-il que les
Allemands soient d'accord, mais il
faudrait que les que la France
redevienne ce pays non aligné qui dit
les intérêts sont plus importants que
tout. La Russie n'était pas notre ennemi
direct, les sanctions pendant la guerre
froide n'ont jamais inclus le gaz. Et
donc si pendant la guerre froide,
lorsque c'était l'ennemi l'empire du
mal, on les a pas incluses, pourquoi pas
cette fois ? Ça veut pas dire devenir
prorusse. Je pense que ça c'est
absolument absolument vital. Mais je
pense aussi même si ça fait identitaire
aussi supprimer l'état providence à
disposition du monde entier. Milton
Friedman disait souvent un état
providence ne tient pas si les
frontières sont ouvertes. Mais c'est
logique si l'État providence vous donne
des énormes avantages, vous allez vous
popériser parce que le monde entier va
profiter des avantages et à un moment
vous aurez plus de soins et donc
l'Europe va être aussi popérisée par une
immigration non choisie. C'est très
important. Alors ça n'explique pas tous
les problèmes. C'est pas le bou
émissaire de l'immigré pas du tout parce
que l'immigré il fait ce qu'il peut
comme il veut. Il va il va eu un
avantage mais il est fou d'avant
d'accorder les mêmes avantages à
l'étranger et au national providence est
déjà en train les rapports diplomatiques
européens
oui
Ursula Voren et la Calasse ils ont pas
trop l'air de prendre ce cheminl ils
vont vous taxer de prusse ou de Poutino
Poutine pentin de
Poutin Poutinolâre ouâre
qui brit
moi j'ai droit à tout he proerbe pro
israélien
Et maintenant c'est prusse
pro parce que vous faites comme ça
et j'ai eu droit. Oui voilà Givelli mais
j'ai eu droit aussi à proéricain lorsque
j'avais un peu défendu.
Vous avez pas eu promosade ?
Si. Oh là là très souvent très souvent.
Et proas aussi. Non pas encore parce que
il faut toujours avoir les deux pour
l'équilibre. Nous on procain
promoosade.
On a été aussi enjuivé parce que comme
comme notre Montor était feuge,
on est forcément juillet. On est
contrôlé par la main de machin.
Alors ce qui est exaspérant quand je dis
à un élève ou un jeune qui me pose une
question que que tout les complots des
juifs qui ourdissent à New York et qui
expliquent le monde entier c'est débile.
Vous savez ce qui me répond ? Vous êtes
très naïf. C'estàdire que l'avantage du
complotisme, c'est que le mec qui sait
rien, il vous traite de naïf parce que
vous êtes pas dans sa logique fermée.
Mais ça ça revient à la mode. Les
théories du du complot juif, ça revient
à la mode.
Ouis. Mais il y a d'autres théories qui
reviennent à la mode. C'est bon, nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est 2200 calories
dans le frigo de tout le monde pour
éviter que les gens se tapent de
alors on aura de plus en plus de mal.
Bon, on a le nucléaire. La France, ça
dépend si vous parlez de la France ou de
l'Europe.
La France d'abord et ensuite l'Europe.
Je vous
La France d'Aurope. J'aurai un deuxième
conseil.
J'en parle depuis des années parce que
ça m'avait fasciné. Il y a 12 ans en
Belgique, j'ai rencontré un ingénieur
qui travaille sur le torium qui est une
filière du nucléaire qui a pratiquement
pas de déchets et le peu de déchets qui
dure quelques centaines d'années et pas
des centaines de milliers, il est
recyclable. Donc c'est un nucléaire
extraordinaire qui est mais on l'a
jamais exploité parce que on a voulu
exploiter la filière de l'uranium parce
qu'il fait il permettait de faire un
double emploi à la fois le nucléaire
civil et militaire. Donc on a abandonné
le torium qui ne faisait que le civil.
Les Chinois sont en avance sur le sur le
torium.
C'est tout ce que vous avez comme
conseil pour nos dirigeurs français.
Non déjà renouveler le nucléaire qui est
celui d'avenir et qui n'a pas de risque
et rétablir une possibilité d'avoir de
l'énergie à bon marché. Ça me paraît
extrêmement important. Limiter les flux
migratoires qui nous paupérisent et qui
tuent l'état social et qui le qui le
détruisent et qui vont le détruire
certainement. Encore une fois, c'est pas
une question de critiquer l'immigration.
C'est c'est structurel. Si si on
accueille toute la misère du monde et et
que les lois européennes et les
conventions inscrites dans le préambule
de la Constitution nous empêche d'avoir
toute politique souveraine et de
limitation des droits, c'est
mathématique. On ne pourra pas nourrir
tout ça et ça va nous coûter. C'est
quand même si on fait déjà ça, vous
savez c'est c'est pas mal. Et bien sûr,
bien sûr, si on parle d'économie, vous
me parlez d'économie, je crois, hein.
Bien sûr, les charges qui pèent sur les
patrons, bah sont folles. Sont folles.
Les les patrons français russes, une des
raisons pour lesquelles ils veulent pas
revenir en France, on a monté leur flat
taxe de 13 à 22 % pour financer la
guerre. 22 % de flat taxe, ça veut dire
ils payent rien de plus en tout. 22 %.
Nous, on doit être si on compte tous les
prélèvements et les taxes ou alors même
74 %. Oui, si on si on compte tous les
prélèvements, c'est 74 et que les taxes,
c'est au moins 50 et apparemment c'est
eux les sovietes et pas nous. Moi, je
dirais c'est nous les Soviettes. Quand
on est à à ce à ce niveau de charge
sociale, pas pour les grandes
multinationales qui elles arrivent à 8 %
tranquillement, mais pour le pour
l'artisan ou le commerçant PME français,
il est massacré de de taxes et ça va
complètement tuer l'économie. Mais ça
c'est certain, ça va ça ça va nous
amener à la mort économique et donc il
est urgent. Alors je sais pas je sais
c'est compliqué à faire. Je sais pas
comment exactement baisser ces taxes
pour mais ensuite c'est sûr qu'on devra
faire un certain nombre d'innovations
pour essayer de faire payer
la géopolitique et la guerre économique
en Europe. Quels sont
censés ils sont censés être nos alliés,
nos partenaires selon vous. Quels sont
nos ennemis en Europe ? les ennemis de
la France, les ennemis qui nous ont mis
des balayettes, nous ont mis des
rochers, nous ont débranché, nous ont
créer des misères, on fait du lobbing
contre nous. Il y a qui en Europe qu'il
faut identifier tout de suite comme des
gens pas très fréquentables ? Alors, ils
sont fréquentables mais à moi, moi je je
sais que c'est c'est choquant pour
beaucoup, mais pour moi, l'ennemi euh
d'un point de vue économique et
géopolitique qui nous empêche d'être
nous-mêmes aujourd'hui et qui qui nous
qui nous met des des pots de banane et
et des attaques, c'est l'Amérique.
L'Amérique depuis
en Europe, on verra le confè en Europe,
pardon. Alors en Europe, en Europe, je
pense que euh c'est pas nos ennemis,
mais c'est ceux qui nous mettent dans la
Moïse, c'est les Baltes, les Polonais et
les Roumains. Euh ce que j'appelle
l'élargissement de l'Europe à des pays
revanchards qui nous entraînent dans une
guerre qui n'est pas la nôtre. De Gaul
disait souvent, si on fait une guerre,
ça doit être la nôtre.
Vous avez pas dit les Allemands direct
parce que les Baltes, bon les les trois
petits confettis là-haut, OK. La Pologne
qui est plus qu'un gros confetti, on
peut l'entendre mais bon là ils sont un
peu loin.
Ça dépend comment on appelle ennemis.
Non d'ennemis des gens qui nous ont mis
des crocheptes.
Oui.
Qui nous ont pris pour des couillons à
nous faire des gros bisous sur la
bouche. Mais en fin de compte c'était
nos ennemis.
Oui. Tout dépend comment on définit
l'ennemi. Nous en stratégie on
il est toujours à abattre. Oui, l'ennemi
c'est celui qui vient vous tuer dans
votre baignoir ou sur votre terrasse. Et
là, vous avez pas de doute que c'est
votre ennemi. Mais effectivement, les
autres c'est les adversaires et des
concurrents. Je dirais que l'Allemagne
est un adversaire et un concurrent mais
l'ennemi alors
j'ai pas réussi à vous le faire dire.
Pourtant, je l'ai bien formulé mais vous
avez mis la tempérance qui va avec les
précautions oratoires.
Oui. OK.
Lemagne est un concurrent et un
adversaire. Mais pour nous en stratégie
euh et en géopolitique, un ennemi, c'est
quand même celui qui va euh attaquer
votre territoire en l'envahissant, tuer
votre population de manière létale, le
tuer physiquement et détruire vos
institutions, bombarder, l'Élysée et ce
donc un un ennemi, c'est quand même très
particulier. C'est pas un
Vous avez jamais fait de guerre
économique vous ? Euh
si. Alors en guerre économique en guerre
économique il y a une ça dépend de la
définition la définition pour l'école de
guerre économique où j'ai enseigné
pendant 1 an avec
bien sûr là et je suis d'accord ça
remonte à Édouard Ludvac Eddouard Ludvac
le grand stratège américain a écrit le
livre Economical warfare et il a
préconisé une guerre économique y
compris contre ceux qui ne sont pas des
ennemis stratégiques. que on peut être
un ami stratégique ou pas un ennemi
stratégique mais on est traité comme un
ennemi d'un point de vue économique. Et
c'est ça la c'est ça la complexité de la
géopolitique. Vous pouvez être un ami
stratégique dans la même alliance mais
on vous fait une guerre économique. Ça
paraît un peu contradictoire mais non
c'est logique de même que l'Inde elle
est l'ennemi elle est l'ennemi de
Pakistan et de la Chine mais elle est
avec eux dans un certain nombre
d'organisations. C'est la complexité de
la géopolitique. Donc je je je vous
rejoins. Il y a une guerre économique
qui est livrée, Miteran l'avait dit dans
le livre de George Marc Benamou, une
guerre économique, une guerre qui n'est
qui ne fait pas couler de sang, mais une
guerre tout de même. Effectivement,
l'Allemagne en ce sens peut être
considérée comme un adversaire et un
concurrent et l'Amérique comme un
ennemi. D'un point de vue économique,
dans la définition non géopolitique
stratégique non militaire, l'Amérique se
conduit comme un ennemi depuis très très
longtemps puisque les lois
extraterritoriales qui nous ont raquetté
littéralement, qui ont failli faire
couler la société générale et la BNP
Paribas, 9 milliards d'amendes pour la
BNP Paribas pour un investissement de
160 millions de dollars. Le
multiplicateur ferait rêver le fisque.
Là, c'est du raquet à l'état pur. C'est
des lois extraterritoriales non
conformes au droit international et
c'est de la véritable guér le le pillage
d'information avec la NSA. Je sais que
ça vous savez par cœur mais pour nos
auditeurs, pour ceux qui ne le sauraient
pas, beaucoup le savent, la NSA avec les
Five Eyes, les les cinq pays
anglo-saxons nous lèv nous livrent une
guerre économique puisque ils échangent
l'information soi-disant au nom de la
lutte contre le terrorisme. Voilà Pipo
comme vous faites. Et en fait tout cela
est utilisé par le renseignement
américain qui est très intelligent. qui
est très imbriqué avec les entreprises
et les entreprises américaines
bénéficient du pillage de données de la
NSA par le système Prisme et les Five
Eyes, donc un échange d'information et
et un pillage de de global de données et
tout ça est utilisé ensuite et est et
fourni de manière très intéressante aux
entreprises américaines qui ont un
avantage comparatif parce que les
données pillées au nom de la lutte
contre le terrorisme les aident à avoir
à à être nos concurrents et de manière
assez déloyale.
Ça c'est la vraie guerre en fait. C'est
non, je dirais qu'il il y a la vraie
guerre militaire et c'est
et a la guerre économique. Ce sont deux
plans différents. Je dirais là, on est
dans dans la symétrie. Ce sont deux
formes de guerres différentes. La guerre
militaire, c'est la guerre économique
qu'on n pas pu cacher et qui arrive
devant les
Ah oui ! Alors, les Américains parlent
de weaponization de la de l'économie.
J'en j'ai un chapitre dans mon de mon
livre là-dessus. la la la militarisation
de de l'économie et de la finance et là
à travers des sanctions qui sont une
forme de guerre mais qui ne fait pas
couler de sang une guerre qui qui qui
qui est qui est qui est prévue pour vous
tuer comme le voulait Bruno Lemire. Sauf
que ces sanctions n'ont pas fonctionné
en tout cas sur la Russie puisque la
Russie contrairement à ce que tout le
monde dit se porte bien, elle est en
surchauffe. Alors il y a eu un taux
d'intérêt très élevé pour éviter la
surchauffe mais il y a pas de chômage.
Les gens trouvent de l'emploi très
facilement parce que justement il y a
une surchauffe. Alors on les paye de
plus en plus et le salaire est plus
élevé que l'inflation. Donc il y a il
n'y a pas une crise économique comme on
va la connaître en Europe. Il y a plutôt
une surchauffe et et les sanctions n'ont
pas fonctionné. Donc la guerre
économique fonctionne hélas, beaucoup
mieux sur nous que sur la Russie.
Sal minimum en Russie, c'est combien ?
Alors le salaire minimum en Russie à ma
connaissance, je pense que c'est euh
entre 700 et 800 € mais peut-être que je
me trompe, il me semble. Vous
vous plantez peut-être la boîte d'œuf,
elle a combien et le litre d'huile, il
est à combien ?
Alors ça, je ne sais pas du tout. C'est
pas c'est pas ma partie. Moi, j'ai pas
j'ai pas acheté de l'huile, j'étais dans
un hôtel.
Mais si si vous savez le le prix, ça
m'intéresse. Non,
moi j'aime bien entendre des stratèges
qui me parlent de choc économique ou de
pas choc économique mais qui connaissent
pas le prix. Ce que je sais ce que je
sais c'est que pourquoi je
Oui. Oui. Non mais ce que je Non, il y a
pas raison de se fâcher. Ce que je sais
c'est que en tout cas l'énergie n'est
pas cher du tout et un russe se chauffe
pour très très peu. Et les logements ont
été acquis par beaucoup de Russes depuis
l'époque libérale après la chute de
l'Union Soviétique. Donc ils ont ils ont
un logement, même s'il est précaire mais
ils ont un logement à eux parce qu'on a
on a vendu on a privatisé les logements
qui av à l'époque étaient public dans
beaucoup d'endroit et l'énergie n'est
pas cher du tout et donc le russe survit
assez bien même dans les campagnes où le
salaire est beaucoup plus bas. Je sais
qu'un pensionné par exemple peut avoir
entre 150 et 200 € de pension. Vous
faisiez allusion à ça ? Ça dépend si on
parle de Moscou ou de la province. En
province le salaire minimum, il est
beaucoup plus bas. Il est un peu près à
300 €. Mais si vous êtes à Moscou, c'est
pas le même niveau de vie. Il y a Moscou
et Saint-Pétersbourg qui est un peu plus
bas, puis il y a le reste de la Russie
qui a pas du tout le même niveau de vie.
Donc tout dépend,
il y a Paris et le reste de la France
pareil. Oui,
revenons revenons à notre prospective
concernant la France et l'Europe avec
des gros nuages noirs
économique.
Un secrétaire général de l'OTAN qui nous
dit "Préparez-vous les gars à un conflit
qui va, je résume trivialement, mais qui
va être aussi sale que ce qu'on vécu nos
parents et nos grands-parents." Un chef
d'étatmajor français qui nous dit "Bon,
dans 3 4 ans, il va falloir se
préparer." Comment vous lisez ? "C'est
une déclaration ? C'est de la panique ?
un message diplomatique à l'intention de
la Russie. C'est c'est de la chat, c'est
de la crainte. Me dites pas, c'est un
peu un mélange de tout ça.
Non, c'est pas c'est pas de
c'est pas que de la chat. Je pense
vraiment que il est possible et ça me
permettra de répondre à une question que
vous avez posé avant à laquelle j'ai
oublié de répondre. Les Russes nous
envoient la mort. après 250000 morts ou
500, certains disent 500 mais Média
disent dit plutôt 270 mais peu importe
après les centaines de milliers de morts
bah vous avez pas le même état d'esprit
que avant. Et donc la Russie peut, c'est
ce que j'appelle la géopolitique
interactive, elle peut avoir changé sa
vision de son propre empire. Ça veut
dire ce qu'elle voulait faire il y a 15
ans n'est pas la même chose que ce
qu'elle voulait faire il y a 10 ans et
il y a 3 ans avec l'invasion de
l'Ukraine et maintenant et après. Donc
il n'est pas tout à fait insincère de la
part des dirigeants qui veulent très
beaucoup armer les pays européens qui
veulent se prémunir en cas d'une
expansion qui va continuer de la Russie
quand on voit les misères que les baltes
font subir aux minorités russes qui sont
quand même assez importantes avec des
suppressions des droits linguistiques et
aussi les attaques sur Calinrade
indirect puisque on a coupé Caliningrade
de de de de l'accès l'accès par la route
et ferroviaire ont a été coupé. la
volonté d'isoler, d'enclaver encore plus
qu'elle ne l'éit qu'à l'iningrad ou de
brimer les minorités russes ou alors la
volonté euh j'ai interrogé l'ambassadeur
de de de Russie en Moldavie pour pour ce
livre justement euh Olegov et il il lui
il dit la Moldavie pourrait être une
prochaine prochaine zone de conflit et
la Moldavie c'est très liée à la
Roumanie avec une présidente Maya Sandou
qui veut se rapprocher petit à petit de
l'OTAN mais déjà de l'Union européenne
mais c'est C'est presque la même chose
puisque l'OTAN l'organisation de défense
de l'Union européenne si vous voulez la
conflictualité peut encore
s'élargir et donc il est logique que
l'Europe veuille s'armer parce qu'elle
est désarmée. On a une ligne magin
nucléaire nous les Français mais mais on
est désarmé. On n pas de drone, on n pas
d'avion transporteur, gros
transporteurs, on n pas assez de
munition, on a des supers armes mais on
n pas les quantités. Parfois on en donne
plus, on en vend plus aux autres que ce
qu'on en a. Et donc euh il y a une
volonté de rattraper euh 30 ans de de
gement footisme. On a réduit tout, on
économise les balles euh quand on fait
euh euh de de du du tir à l'armée et
donc c'est pas forcément une mauvaise
intention. Et il est possible que après
250000 ou 500000 morts, certains 1700000
morts, les Russ les Russes ne soient
plus dans le même état d'esprit et
peut-être que ils se préparent à une
guerre. Moi, il me l'avait dit en 2012
que ils étaient prêts à la guerre
totale. Donc c'est pas bête. Et je pense
que tout ce qu'a fait Macron, c'est pas
forcément euh stupide. C'est
probablement un mensonge. La Russie
n'est pas l'ennemi existentiel de la
France, mais un mensonge pour une pour
une bonne idée. Réarmer la France qui
s'est trop désarmée, c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle si la France s'arme,
s'équipe à une armée qui tient la route,
achète fabrique un peu de drone parce
que la guerre aujourd'hui se gagne
beaucoup par les drones si c'est si ça
dure un peu et que qu'il a des troupes
au sol, si c'est pas juste des
bombardements de 15 jours aérien et donc
c'est plutôt quelque chose d'assez
logique. Alors la chat, je sais pas si
si c'est de la chat mais les Européens
savent très bien ce qu'ils ont fait aux
Russes. Si on se met à la place des
Russes, si on se met à la place des
Russes un instant comme on fait en
géopolitique pour les Russes, nous
sommes responsables de la mort de
centaines de milliers de Russes. Alors
pourquoi Russ c'est 298 € ?
Voilà voilà. Mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que nous on se met jamais à la
place de l'autre. Pour nous c'est une
guerre défensive. Pour les Russes c'est
une guerre offensive. Quand nous armons
des Ukrainiens pour tuer des Russes, les
Russes le perçoivent. Ils se sont mêlés
d'une guerre qui n'est pas la leure.
L'Ukraine n'était pas dans l'OTAN, ni
dans l'Union européenne. Il n'y avait
pas de traité de défense à l'époque.
Donc quand ils ont armé les Ukrainiens
pour tuer 250000 ou 700000 Russes, ils
nous ont agressé. Je sais que c'est ça
paraît prusse, c'est pas ce que je
pense, mais c'est important de voir
comment l'autre perçoit. Les Russes
perçoivent ça comme une agression
puisque nous n'étions pas concernés.
C'est comme pour la Serbie ou pour
d'autres ou d'autres cas. Donc ils se
disent, ils nous ont agressé et ils ont
tué nos concitoyens. Ce qu'on leur fait
subir en ce moment avec quelques drones
qui vont explorer quelques sites, c'est
rien par rapport à ce qu'on aurait dû
leur faire. Dans le livre, je parle
aussi de bombardement stratégique
d'avions qui peuvent qui peuvent
transporter des missiles nucléaires
jusqu'à 5000 km dans la profondeur russe
alors que il ces avions étaient visibles
dans le cadre de New Start qui va
expirer bientôt. C'est-à-dire il y avait
une confiance entre les deux pays. Mais
c'est grave parce que les Russes se
disent "OK, même quand on avait des
deals avec les Américains où chacun
montrait les avions de l'autre, ils en
ont profité pour nous pour attaquer nos
bombardiers stratégiques. Si les Russes
avaient voulu répondre symétriquement,
ils auraient attqué attaqué des
bombardiers stratégiques qui peuvent
transporter du nucléaire dans des pays
de l'OTAN où
c'était les Ukrain qui se farcissaient
les bombardiers russes.
Mais pour les Russes, c'est quand même
avec des radars et des satellites
américains et et et des instructeurs et
des forces spéciales et beaucoup de
militaires de plusieurs pays de
l'Europe. Pour les Russes, c'est quand
même une agression et et dans la mesure
où celui qui avait un accord new start
de gentleman agreement, je montre mes
avions, tu montre le tien, mais
j'indique à mon allié comment bombarder
tes avions. Non, c'est un viol direct du
traité new start. Donc il n'y a plus
aucun accord de désarmement et aucune
confiance entre la Russie et les pays de
l'OTAN et l'Amérique et les Européens.
Et donc Trump, lui, il a compris que
c'est extrêmement dangereux. La
situation est beaucoup plus grave et
beaucoup plus dangereuse et a beaucoup
plus de risques d'engrenage nucléaire
aujourd'hui que dans les pires heures de
la guerre froide. Parce que
même la crise de Cuba euh pépit.
Ah oui, parce que la crise du pas, on le
sait, c'était du théâtre. La crise de
Cuba, euh on fait croire que Kennedy
risque le tout pour le tout, qui fait
plier les Russes. Mais en fait, ils
avaient fait exprès de de décaler de 6
mois le démantellement de de de de
domicile
américain en Turquie. Et en fait c'était
je retire, tu retires. Il y avait un
super deal mais on a fait croire que
c'était et les Russes ont ce côté froid,
ils ont laissé les Américains se vanter
mais en fait c'était un deal. Et donc
euh là, on on est on avait encore des
gens, c'est des adultes à la tête des
stratèges et et des états. Il y avait
encore des adultes, ils savaient faire
des deals, ils enregistraient pas euh
par traîrise un accord, euh une
discussion stratégique. Il filmait pas
dans les réseaux sociaux euh ce qui
avait été dit juste avant dans une
réunion stratégique. Il y avait des il y
avait des réunions secrètes où les mecs
avaient un sens quand même de la parole
tous les deux. C'est fini tout ça
maintenant. même une même une discussion
euh euh avec assez grave en privé, ben
on va faire un commentaire sur les
réseaux sociaux.
Donc là à l'opposé à l'époque, il y
avait des adultes. Maintenant, on a quoi
? On a que des prépubères, des
adoptions.
On a des alors c'est pas des prépubères
parce qu'ils sont quand même assez
prédateurs de temps en temps, mais c'est
plutôt des communicateurs. Je m'en
fousiste en Italie, on dit fruismo. Ils
en ont rien à Ils en ont rien à
après eux. Regardez Sarco avec
son propre parti quand il est parti.
Regarde, ils en ont rien à de
l'après. Ils font ils font ils
déstabilisent l'Afrique. Euh il ils ont
permis l'armement de tous les
djihadistes dans le Sahel en en
déstabilisant la Libye. Ils ont euh ils
ont fait la guerre en Irak soi-disant
pour endiguer leurs ennemis. Ça a permis
de donner l'Irak aux Iraniens. On se
alors là, on voit pas en quoi c'était
une opération qui était livrée pour les
intérêts des États-Unis. Donc en plus,
c'est en plus c'est des plans qui
foirent. C'est c'est on fait des
ingénieries sociales, des ingénieries
politiques et des ingénieries militaires
en croyant qu'on va on va faire un coup.
Mais c'est c'est c'est de la comm. C'est
comme les terroristes. Quand les
terroristes nous font des sales coups et
qu'on bombarde des positions
terroristes, bah ça fait pas de
terroristes de moins, ça en fait quatre
de plus ou cinq de plus. C'est les
mathématiques inversées. Si vous voulez,
on est parce qu'on est toujours dans la
réaction dans la com. On va démontrer
que c'est comme quand monsieur Trump
avait bombardé la Syrie hein pendant son
premier mandat où l'Iran récemment ça
n'a pas tué le problème puisque les les
500 kg euh les 500 tonnes d'uranium sont
toujours à la disposition des Iraniens.
Ils ont toujours la possibilité. C'est
le dernier rapport de la CIA qui a été
résumé dans un livre là qui est publié
chaque année en France qui le dit
lui-même hein. Ils ont toujours la
possibilité de faire des bombes
atomiques. Donc si vous voulez c'est que
de la com et surtout c'est pas sérieux
parce que l'idée c'est moi je fais de la
com
élu. Je veux être réélu. Là, il y a des
sondages et mes spin doctors et mes et
mes conseillers public relation, ils
m'expliquent que là ce qui est en vog,
c'est tel hashtag, c'est tel slogan, tel
costume à porortter, tel t-shirt. Bruno
Lemer, le mec qui voulait ruiner la
Russie, on lui a même conseillé qu'il
fallait parler de son sexe dans la
douche dans dans son livre de faire une
petite allusion. On
je sais pas ont mais en tout cas, je
veux pas entendre.
Oui, ben on ou moi je dis pas de source.
Moi je dis ben non mais la source c'est
le livre, il suffit de le lire. Il
raconte un moment c'est comment il
s'occupe dans sa baignoire de son sex
conseillé ça.
Moi je pense que ce sont des conseillers
pas de source vous pensez
ou alors admettons que ça soit lui ça
revient même de toute façon ça ne
détruit pas ce que je voulais dire
c'est une supp
même non mais même si c'est lui
admettons que c'est pas on même si c'est
lui. Non mais même si c'est oui mais ça
me gêne pas ce que vous dites. Même si
c'est lui.
Moi ça me gêne ce que vous
moi ça me gêne pas. Même si c'est lui.
Non mais c'est pas grave. Bah c'est pas
grave la source. Je vais vous dire
pourquoi. Parce que ce que je veux
démontrer c'était pas la source, c'était
le fait que il a jugé bon, admettons, il
a jugé bon de dire que il touchait son
sexe dans la douche parce qu'il pense
que c'est en comm Oui, j'ai lu j'ai j'ai
aussi lu le livre de Frédéric Mitteran
qui racontait quand je me fais
par un jeune des banlieux, je ressens la
revanche sociale.
Ça ça c'est marqué noir sur blanc parce
que on a connu ce truc.
Ouais, d'accord. Non non mais c'est le
livre qui je respecte cet homme. Il
raconte quelque chose qu'il vit avec
une diversion une diversion.
Oui. Oui. Parce que de toute façon il il
y a rien de sous le coup de la loi de ce
que je viens de dire parce que c'est
écrit en tout le grand écrivain qui
sommeille en Bruno Lemer. Vous lui
prêtez peut-être des intentions qu'il
n'avait même pas.
Non je pense que franchement il pense
que pour communiquer il faut être un peu
dans le vent. Bah c'est comme la série
Netflix, il y a un truc super sérieux,
les séries ou alors Homeland et
compagnie. Puis tout à coup, il faut une
scène de cul un peu crache parce que
c'est c'est c'est à la mode. C'est comme
ça que maintenant on communique. On de
même que moi avec mes étudiants un
moment pour attirer leur attention, je
vais faire un petit gros mot. C'est
c'est c'est de la com. C'est de la com.
Voilà. Sauf qu'en politique, c'est
beaucoup plus grave parce que là on est
dans la superficialité alors que on
devrait avoir des gens responsables.
Voilà ce que je voulais dire, c'est
tout. Mais le on n'est pas si grave. les
comment vous le voyez euh comment vous
voyez l'avenir de ces gens responsables
? Si la situation économique se dégrade
comme ça va se dégrader, si la monnaie
européenne se disloque,
si l'Europe se disloque, vous vous le
voyez comment euh le camp de vilégiature
de ceux qui décident en ce moment et des
plans qui ont pas l'air de de
fonctionner. Vous les voyez bien, moins
bien ? Je pense que bon ça va ça va mal
finir pour nous tous, ça c'est certain
parce qu'on va tous crever un jour ou
l'utre. Est-ce des mots sur mal finir en
dehors de crever ?
Oui. Voilà. Mal finir non déjà c'est un
présupposé. Ça va mal finir de toute
façon mais là où ça va mal finir plutôt
que prévu, c'est que comme nos
dirigeants n'ont rien prévu, ils n'ont
pas voulu prévoir. Or la politique c'est
prévoir. Ils n'ont pas voulu planifier.
Ils n'ont pas voulu écouter les
stratèges. Ils n'ont pas n'ont pas voulu
écouter les services de renseignement.
Ils n'ont pas voulu écouter ce qui les
avertissait par exemple sur l'échec de
l'intégration. Bah si vous mettez à la
disposition des musulmans de France les
salafistes, les frères musulmans et le
miliguluche, ben vous allez pas en faire
des des des super républicains. Euh
c'est pareil pour l'économie, pour
l'ultr taxation, vivre sur la dette
et et tous les problèmes énergétiques
qu'on a soulevé ou par exemple l'abandon
du torium qui était un truc d'avenir que
les Chinois les Chinois sont premiers
dans le torium. B, on a des des
stratèges, on dit dans les années euh
euh 60 70, le Toriums, il aurait jamais
fallu l'abandonner, mais on l'a
abandonné. Donc si vous voulez, c'est
comme ça partout dans dans dans tous les
domaines. Euh une société qui est une
société de com de communication et de
l'instant où on est que dans l'instant,
société du spectacle, vous ne pouvez pas
avoir des gens qui font euh une
politique de long terme. Et
deuxièmement, une démocratie qui devient
démagogique. C'est les fameux cycles
politiques analysés par Palaton et
Aristote. On est dans dans la phase
connue des Grecs depuis depuis des des
des très très longtemps. On est dans une
perversion. La la démocratie est le
meilleur système lorsqu'il est
responsable avec des gens qui ont un
sens de l'intérêt national et de la
cité. Mais la démocratie est le est pire
au niveau efficacité. Il est moins
efficace qu'une qu'un régime autoritaire
lorsque les démocrates en question sont
irresponsables. Ne pensent qu'à la
réélection immédiate n'ont plus le sens
de la patrie de l'intérêt national.
C'est le pire et le meilleur des
systèmes. Et là, on est dans la phase du
pire parce que on est dans une phase
qu quand je pose la question sur nos
dirigeants ou ceux qui prennent les
décisions maintenant, vous les voyez se
réduire
en devenant autoritaire.
Ah oui et oui parce que forme
bah ça c'est le cycle toujours de que
que montrent les philosophes grecs hein.
La démocratie vertueuse elle est
pervertie quand elle devient démagogie.
La démagogie fait rentrer tout le
système dans un chaos et après le chaos
ben il y a un muscle qui arrive et qui
dit "Je vais remettre de l'ordre." Et
donc la phase d'après la phase chaotique
qui est elle-même victime de enfin qui
est le fruit de de la dérive démagogique
anarchique de la démocratie lorsque les
dirigeants ne sont plus virtueux. Après
c'est le despot. Euh alors il y a des
bons despots pour les Grecs, c'est
despot éclairés et là c'est le despot
pas forcément éclairé. Et donc je pense
que les démocraties vont se réduire de
plus en plus. Ça va être
l'hyperfliquage, l'hypercôle. On
arrivera, je pense, vers l'abolition euh
de de de la monnaie métallique, comme on
dit en Espagne, euh métallique. Donc le
le le la la la les billets, les les
pièces, on va aller dans une société qui
sera de plus en plus digitalisée et
hyper contrôlée et on va avoir une
réduction des libertés qui a déjà
commencé, on a vu, hein. Et bizarrement,
c'est pas contre tout le monde. On a
interdit RT et C8 mais bizarrement El
Jazzira n'a pas été interdite. la
la télé qui prêche l'antisémitisme
depuis toujours. Moi une fois, j'étais à
Eljra, donc là je parle du concret, vous
aimez les sources, j'étais dans une
émission d'El Jazzira et j'étais le
salot parce que je disais que en France,
il y a des lois qui condamnent la
négation de la choa et c'est plutôt
probablement une bonne chose, même si
j'aime j'aime pas les limitations à la
liberté. Je disais en France, bah on ne
peut pas être un un antisémite forconné
ou révisionniste. Et j'étais le salot
parce que dans l'émission euh le les
autres, il y avait un type des frères
musulmans, il y avait un présentateur
pourtant qui était chrétien jordanien
mais et et j'étais le salot. Moi,
j'étais le le type en juivé qui qui
représentait cette Europe qui était pour
la la liberté supprimée et et eux
c'étaient des gens fantastiques parce
que ils étaient pour la liberté y
compris de d'être antisémite et d'être
complotiste et d'être révisionniste.
Donc une télé comme ça, imaginez si
c'était la télé du RN. Le
présentateur présentateur le présent.
Alors, j'ai pas vu cette émission et
mais le présentateur sur ma chaîne
YouTube.
Le présentateur, il a mis du calme au
milieu de tout ça pour respecter les
même pas en privé. J'ai dîné avec lui
après c'était Eljir Londres. J'ai pris
j'ai dîné en privé avec lui. Je suis
d'accord avec toi et cetera. Mais l'
Jazzira, il sait où il est. Euh, il a
fait celui qui était indigné par mon
côté liberticide, moi qui condamnais
l'antisémitisme. Et il était très très
euh empathique avec ceux euh qui étaient
du côté de de l'antisémitisme absolu.
Imaginez si la télé était de droite,
elle aurait été interdit et ses
présentateurs emprisonnés. Bah cette
télé qui fait ce genre de chos
régulièrement ou qui a qui a souvent été
le porte-parole des shababes mais
ils ont été peut-être il y a eu des
remont
quelque chose comme ça. Alors peut-être
que alors peut-être que l'Arcom a a fait
des mises en demeure mais pour l'instant
ça n'a jamais été interdit. Elgés n'a
jamais été interdit en Europe. Les
les les démocraties européennes
Oui.
l'Allemagne qui se réarme.
Qui remet son service militaire. Volon
pas volontaire payé pas payé.
Oui,
la conscription qui revient à prix.
Oui, même dans les pays du nord aussi.
Dans les pays du nord,
que va faire l'Allemagne sans énergie
bon marché parce qu'elle va pas se
retourner d'ici 15 ans avec les mêmes
tarifs une fois qu'elle sera réarmée et
surendettée.
Hm.
H
Moi, je pense que l'Allemagne un jour
reprendra du gaz russe parce que tout
elle reprendra du gaz russe par la paix
ou par la force ?
Par la paix. Pourquoi ? parce
qu'aujourd'hui les Américains et les
Russes sont en train de négocier
et que l'Allemagne est une tête de pont
américaine. C'est ça
pas uniquement. C'est plutôt que
aujourd'hui on a des négociateurs du
business des deux côtés euh qui veulent
faire revenir les entreprises
américaines
dans les dans les puits de pétrole et et
et de gaz en Russie. Et dans les
derniers échanges qui ont eu lieu entre
les deux pays, euh échange très concret
en vue de la paix, il y a l'idée de
lever les sanctions euh mondiales euh
soi-disant international sur l'énergie
russe en Europe. Pourquoi les Américains
seront favorables à cette levée ? parce
qu'ils vont être associés à la vente
même Nordstream 1 et 2, il y a un
certain nombre d'entreprises
d'hydrocarbure américaine qui ont dit on
aimerait avoir une option pour
réinvestir dans Nordstream 1 et 2. Le
comble c'est que les Américains ont ont
vraiment souhaité en tout cas ça on peut
l'affirmer parce qu'il y a une vidéo de
monsieur Biden qui dit "On s'en chargera
de Nordstream 1 et 2 s'il ne l'arrête
pas." Donc même si c'est pas prouvé que
c'est eux, on a la fameuse vidéo de Joy
Biden qui le dit, le comble, ils nous
ont privé
tant qu'il y a pas la preuve.
Voilà, ils ont pas la preuve. On a juste
une vidéo qui montre qu'en tout cas ils
avaient ils étaient ils avaient un
intérêt. Leur président a dit que
c'était quand même mieux si on se
débarrassait de leur stream et
oui mais la déclaration de Biden
absolument on désigne personne. Mais
Biden était clair
quand il la journaliste lui pose la
question la vidéo est très connue, elle
est virale. On lui dit mais vous allez
vous allez vous débarrasser de
Nordstream 1 et 2. Vous inquiétez pas,
on va s'en occuper. Voilà donc c'est
très intéressant mais bizarrement c'est
ceux qui voulaient pas. Regardez,
monsieur Trump que l'on accuse souvent
d'être prorusse dans son pendant son
premier mandat. C'est l'homme qui a le
plus bataillé contre Nordstream 1 et 2.
Et là, il est en train de demander aux
Européens d'accepter le retour de
l'énergie russe en Europe parce que ses
potes, parce que lui c'est l'homme du
lobby des des pétroliers, ces potes vont
être associés au business, excusez-moi
dans tout des mots américains mais au au
marché. le la commercialisation du gaz
russe étant associé à des entreprises
américaines, là le gaz russe, les
Américains ne vont pas trouver à redire.
Et c'est les ce sont les dernières
négociations qui ont eu lieu entre
Jarette Kusner, Jarette Kuchner et
Dimitriev et et aussi bien sûr Steve
Witkoff et également qui concorde avec
la visite de Black Rock en Ukraine ces
jours-ci accompagné de Jarette Kruchner.
Il y a beaucoup de négociations
aujourd'hui entre ukrainiens, américain
et et et russes et les Européens de
l'Ouest n'ont pas leur mots à dire.
L'élite européenne politique, vous avez
pas l'impression que c'est des zates du
clan Biden, Obama ou Clinton ?
Après, j'ai un convaincu, c'est la thèse
de mon livre. L'Amérique se déglobalise.
Elle abandonne ce que John Ikenberry qui
est un un analyste universitaire très
connu aux États-Unis de Princeton avait
appelé l'ordre international libéral
fondé sur des règles. Des règles bien
sûr qui sont pas l'ordre international.
L'OIL a été mis en place pour masquer
l'empire américain et le légitimer à
travers
C'est un terme que vous avez inventé.
Non non non, c'est le terme c'est pour
ça que je cite Johnny Cabri parce que
quand on dit OEL ça fait un peu
complotiste. C'est le terme qu'un
défenseur de l'Oyel a inventé. Il
s'appelle John Ink. Ekenberry, je le
cite dans mon livre et dans des articles
qu'on peut retrouver très facilement, il
dit "L'ordre international libéral fondé
sur sur des règles est quelque chose qui
va permettre de masquer, de légitimer et
de faire vivre plus longtemps l'empire
américain qui n'apparaîtra pas comme
tel." Il l'explique dans un liv dans un
article extrêmement intéressant. Pour ça
que j'ai repris, c'est le fil rouge de
mon livre, l'OIL. Mais bizarrement
aujourd'hui l'Amérique veut se
débarrasser de cette Ou qui est plutôt
démocrate. C'est l'Amérique le Global
America de de de Joey Biden. Au moment
où l'Amérique se débarrasse de l'OIL, de
l'OIL, bizarrement c'est celui qui en
était l'une des victimes, le
protectorat, le vassalisé, celui qui
était la cible de cette guerre
économique de l'Uel qui lui en est le
plus grand défenseur. C'est assez
extraordinaire. il a été inventé pour
légitimer l'empire américain avec ses
compli, ses normes parce que l'Amérique
ne gère pas que par le dollar et les
guerres, elle gère aussi euh l'humanité.
Elle elle par des normes, des compli,
les banques, même les écoles de
commerce, même moiême mon école l'PAG,
euh il y a il y a des normes qui ont été
conçues par les Américains. Les banques
ont des compli
c'était aussi un système normatif.
Aujourd'hui, les plus grands défenseurs
qui veulent poursuivre l'O et bien ce
sont les Européens et ceux qui l'ont
inventé. Les Américains tant qu'il a
qu'il y a Trump veulent s'en débarrasser
parce que c'était devenu un fardeau qui
coûtait trop cher et qui les dispersait.
Ils veulent se ils veulent ils veulent
maintenant un monde multipolaire euh qui
va euh en gros euh donner une doctrine
Mollerro élargie aux Américains. C'est
la fameuse corollaire Trump hein. Les
Américains jusque euh jusqu'aux
Frontières du Brésil, Caraïbe jusqu'au
Grenland et cetera. Les Européens, on va
les vassaliser mais à moindre frais, à
leur propre coût et à leur propre
risque. Les Chinois, on va faire un deal
probablement. Je pense qu'il y aura un
deal sur je pense, je suis pas sûr, mais
sur Taiïwan et les Russes, on va faire
un deal avec eux. On va faire un nouveau
Yalta. Là pour l'instant on parle de
Yalta économique depuis l'interview de
politico et la la directive et et le
Conseil national de sécurité la sécurité
nationale, la fameuse le fameux rapport
qui est sorti, on a on en a beaucoup
parlé NSS, elle prévoit une sorte de de
partage de zone d'influence. Donc
finalement l'Amérique est devenue
multipolariste d'une certaine manière,
même si elle reste unilatérale et
impériale. Elle accepte un monde molaire
avec un partage d'influence et de zone
d'influence. Et nous et nous l'Europe,
nous sommes le dindon de la farce que
Trump appelle les faibles. Mais ça
rejoint Hubert Vedrine qui parlait de
l'impuissance volontaire de l'Europe. Et
c'est logique, c'est structurel.
L'Europe, elle est faite de nations
tellement différentes avec des langues
différentes, des rancunes, des
histoires, des positions différentes. Il
est presque impossible avant 300 ans ou
200 ans, il est presque impossible de
faire une Europe qui a une souveraineté
européenne, une Europe fédérale. C'est
ce que disait mon maître général Galois.
Il disait, on peut pas construire une
véritable souveraineté supranationale
européenne à cause des barrages
nationaux. Mais on a perdu quand même
une partie des souverainetés des
nations. L'Europe est faible, elle est
en danger parce que elle est en
apesanteur. Elle n'est elle est en zone
de non souveraineté. Ce que j'appelle le
la désouverainisation. L'Europe est
désouverainisée. Elle n'a pas de vraie
souveraineté supranationale. D'ailleurs,
elle est considérée comme un acteur
comique. C'est un OGENI, objet
géopolitique non identifié. Mais les
États qui sont quand même encore
souverains et qui empêchent la
souveraineté suprationale, eux sont
moins souverains euh que que ce qu'on
devrait l'être quand on l'est vraiment.
Et donc nous sommes pas souverains du
tout. Nous sommes un enjeu pour l'empire
chinois, un enjeu économique, un enjeu
identitaire pour l'empire turc néootoman
qui veut se se élargir sa profondeur
stratégique. C'est la doctrine de
Davutolo qui avait conseillé Erdogan. On
est euh aussi un enjeu pour les
Américains qui ne refourguent leur leur
leur gaz de chiste et leurs armes. Et on
a un enjeu aussi pour un autre empire
qui lui est virtuel, qui n'est pas
incarné dans un état, ce que j'appelle
l'empire salafiste takfiriste, qui lui
profite de de la non intégration de de
de de la difficulté d'assimilation d'une
d'un certain nombre de populations pour
essayer d'en faire ce que la CIA avait
analysé il y a 15 ans comme des
possibles enclaves civilisationnels et
le rapport de la NSS dit des zones où où
il y aura un effacement civilisationnel
parce qu'ils disent pas toute l'Europe,
certains pays européens, il nomment
notamment la Suède, la Belgique et et et
la et l'Angleterre, il y aura des zones
à la fois désouverainisé et hétérogène
avec des enclaves civilisationnels de
contreciété, de contre droit et et et et
de et et antagoniste d'un point de vue
culturel, religieux et politique. Donc
c'est quand même un tableau assez
sombre. Mais tout cela était
parfaitement prévisible. Moi, je me
rappelle quand j'étais jeune
fonctionnaire,
on me traitait de tout parce que je
disais ça va ça va être l'horizon d'un
côté Mad Max puisque des pays qui ont
dévalorisé le régalien comme la France,
comme pratiquement tous les pays de
l'Union européenne, pas les pays de
l'Est, ils sont beaucoup plus régaliens,
mais les pays de l'Ouest européen ont
également fait une autre erreur. Ils ont
par culpabilité feinte, ils ont dit pour
qu'il n'y ait plus jamais ça, pour qu'il
n'y ait plus jamais les heures sombres
de de l'Europe qui reviennent et cetera,
pour que l'Europe ne redevienne pas
facho nazi, il y a une seule solution,
c'est Abermas, le fameux philosophe à la
mode qui est le philosophe de référence
de la Commission européenne. Il faut
tuer l'identité. Il faut que l'Europe ne
devienne qu'un empire normatif. Il
appelle ça le patriotisme juridico
constitutionnel. Il faut remplacer toute
géopolitique civilisationnelle ou
politique de civilisation comme disait
Geno, il faut la remplacer par
uniquement la norme, le droit et les
droits de l'homme. C'est ce qui est dans
les préambules des constitutions. Donc
cette dérégalisation, cette
désouverainisation des États, cette
dévaluation de l'intérêt national, de la
patrie, de l'identité nous rend
extrêmement vulnérable. Parce que quand
vous n'avez plus une géopolitique
civilisationnelle, le Qatar est votre
allié. Celui qui finance la non
intégration, la désassimilation, le
désavouement, comme disent les
islamistes chez vous, c'est pas c'est
pas un ennemi parce que on on ne juge
plus de l'ennemi ou de l'ami en fonction
de la civilisation, de l'identité, de la
continuité historique de votre état,
mais on la juge uniquement à travers de
critères soit normatifs, soit des
critères pognons, hein, d'où les
conférences à 250000 € que l'on peut
faire au Qatar quand on a un homme
politique connu. Et si vous voulez tout
ça, c'est quand même lourd. On a parlé
d'économie, d'énergie, maintenant on
parle d'identité, des souverainisation,
dérégalisation, dévaluation totale de
l'intérêt national et même de l'idée de
nation. Et donc nous sommes le continent
OGNI, un objet géopolitique non
identifié qui va devenir une teranolius
et les différents empire parce que nous
sommes dans les néoempires, la Chine, la
Turquie, l'empire virtuel islamique, je
dis virtuel parce qu'il il a plus de
base depuis qu'il a perdu Daesh, Syrie,
Irak, cet empire mais aussi l'empire
américain. Donc c'est ces différents
prédateurs voient l'Europe comme quelque
chose quand même. C'est magnifique
l'Europe, c'est magnifique. C'est encore
un peu prospère. C'est c'est un
magnifique Eldorado qui va devenir une
magnifique zone de vilégiature et les
différents empires vont essayer de
tailler des parts du marché. Je pense
que ça c'est l'avenir de l'Europe. Et il
y a un autre un autre avenir qui est un
peu plus noir, c'est ce que j'avais
appelé dans un article l'horizon Madmax,
la dérégalisation, la dévaluation des
forces de l'ordre, l'inflict qui tue, le
la police tue et cetera. Cette ce côté
anarchisant, comment
elle tue pas la police ? Bah, elle tue
pas bien sûr, mais c'est ce fameux
slogan des antiflic la police tu
cartons. Ouais, il y a des cartons avec
des mecs qui
il y a des gens qui tuent parfois mais
la police tue c'est la folie de dire ça.
Mais cette idée que le régalien est le
mauvais, ça c'est la grande idée de
l'Europe depuis euh une quarantaine
d'années, depuis un peu près 68. L'idée
c'est CRSS. En fait, la violence
légitime normalement dans une
démocratie, elle elle est celle de
l'État. Mais la grande idée depuis 68,
c'est que la violence légitime, c'est le
rebelle. C'est Cheekvara, c'est le
rebelle, c'est le révolutionnaire, c'est
la désobéissance civique. Et par contre
la violence légitime de l'État, elle est
fascisante.
Vous connaissez les bayonnettes
intelligentes ?
Non.
Ah, ce serait très intéressant que vous
appreniez ce petit concept. L'ordre
mélien, le dialogue mélien, ça vous
parle ?
Omélien.
Mélien
Mélien. Non,
le dialogue Mélien non plus.
Non plus.
Revenons. Revenons à à nos champignons.
Ça m'intéresse si vous m'expliquez.
Ouais, mais j'ai pas trop le temps.
D'accord. une
sinon je vous emmène dans un sous-marin
et puis je vous fais boire un bol d'eau
à 300 m.
D'accord. Non, ça non.
Ça va. Elle est très bonne. Elle est
fraîche.
Je préfère J'aime bien l'air.
L'air frais.
Revenons à nos moutons. On est inquiet
pour le pays. On est inquiet pour
l'Europe. On est plus inquiet pour le
pays que pour l'Europe, même si c'est
nos copain. Et on voit une bande de
dirigeants.
Ça ressemble plus à des gentils
organisateurs du club M ou à des bafas
du de l'UCPA plutôt qu'il y a des grands
stratèges, des grands diplomates, des
mecs qui sont des poignées de mains
d'homme et qui tiennent leurs mots,
tiennent leurs paroles. On voit les
Russes en train de se fâcher. On voit
tout le monde en train de se fâcher. On
voit comme vous l'avez bien vous l'avez
très bien décrit l'Europe qui vient un
peu le le lubrifiant d'autres empires
qui se repaisse de notre carcasse encore
chaude.
Notre population française dans sa
globalité. Qu'est-ce qui se passe s'il y
a une tiermondisation de la France
encore plus qu'à l'heure actuelle ?
encore plus de maladies moyen-ageuses
qui débarquent, de principes
sécuritaires moyenageux et de j'en passé
des meilleurs moyenageux. Qu'est-ce qui
va se passer en France selon ?
C'est là, on va encore plus déprimer
avec cette question.
Non non, on n'est pas là pour déprimer.
On est là pour prendre les voir les
choses en face,
la guerre, la géopolitique et anticiper
correctement. On faisait allusion aux
épidémies si j'ai bien compris ou
pas aux épidémies mais une tiendisation
quand on voit de la tuberculose qui
remonte de la gale qui remonte des des
saloperies qu'on a pas vu depuis 150
ans.
C'est sûr que quand on est ouvert à tous
euh c'est beaucoup plus difficile avoir
une politique sanitaire. Moi je vois
quand on voit
c'est quand on est ouvert à tous. Je
suis pas d'accord avec vous parce que
normalement tout le monde en France a la
CMU. Tout le monde peut se faire
diagnostiquer sa gale ça teigne ou quoi
que ce soit. Pour l'instant ça tient
quand même. Ce que je disais quand on
est pas c'est pas les mouvements. Je
veux bien je veux bien que on n pas
encore de fièvre Ébola qui vient
d'Afrique centrale.
Alors Ebola effectivement c'est une
lige. Il est toujours resté assez
cantonné Ebola. Heureusement parce que
Ebola là c'est
90% % de chance de mourir dans une mort
assez atroce. C'est un miracle. Ebola a
est resté assez confiné mal. Mal
malheureusement marfant.
Pardon.
Un petit marfant.
Mais non et bon là ce serait absolument
le presque le pire. Mais non, je pense
que quand on est ouvert à tous,
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes non
seulement ouverts à une immigration
massive légale de peuplement
regroupement familial, mais aussi
perméable à une immigration illégale
totalement incontrôlée du fait qu'on a
dépénalisé l'immigration clandestine et
que beaucoup de pays ne veulent pas
réadmettre et que quand vous francichez
le sol, moi j'étais pour une enquête à
l'AMP1 et le maire est content parce
qu'il dit "Ils arrivent tous comme avant
mais il reste pas à l'AMP12 mais ils
arrivent tous parce que de toute façon
les lois européennes aujourd'hui empêche
totalement de faire ce qu'a fait
l'Australie. Donc cette cette ces masses
qui viennent de pays qui ont beaucoup
plus de problèmes sanitaires avec des
pays où l'eau vous vous tue. On a
forcément plus de maladie. Mais ça c'est
un tabou parce que ça fait que c'est
plus résistant ils sont peut-être plus
résistants à d'autres trucs
mais pas nous. Vous savez qu'on a tué
les Indiens d'Amérique en partie, pas
que par des massacres, mais
et voilà. Donc euh euh quand quand on
est ouvert à tous et sans contrôle les
mecs viennent pas avec de la vari
euh non mais euh on aura de plus en plus
de maladie. D'ailleurs les les virus
qu'on a qu'on a chopé de Chine c'est les
revers de la mondialisation et on n'est
pas préparé pour à la limite pourquoi
pas c'est c'est c'est un dommage. Non
non non c'est pas
les revers de la circulation des
personnes
ou c'est parce que si si on a des gars
qui prennent l'avion et qu'on a pas de
ministère de la santé qui nous mettent
des affichés à qu sanitaires à Charles
de Gaulle parce qu'on a une
correspondance direct one. One, je
dirais pas que c'est un problème de
mondialisation, je dirais que c'est un
problème de crétin qui pas correctement
la la la géopolite. C'est vrai qu'à
Singagapour la mondialisation elle est
contrôlée. Vous n'entrez pas n'importe
comment et pendant le virus c'était
on a bien compris que les frontières
vous intéressaient.
Mais c'est important. C'est la base de
la géopolitique les frontières.
Revenons à l'énergie.
Oui.
Au travail, au chômage à tout ça. Les
conditions de guerre économique sont
délétaires.
Oui.
Partout où on pose notre regard, c'est
des terrains de mort comme le dit Sunzu
des neuf terrains.
H
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait selon vous ? Si
vous aviez trois trois conseils à donner
par exemple à Stéphane Séjourné à
l'Europe ou notre ministre
notre ministre de n'importe quoi. Non,
Stéphane Sne
alors pour ce qui concerne l'Europe, je
pense et c'est c'est une évidence comme
l'a proposé le Danemark il y a de jours
et l'Angleterre
soit réviser considérablement soit
sortir des Conventions européennes des
droits de l'homme et autres traités qui
ont été inscrits dans les constitutions
et qui empêchent d'être souverain.
Aujourd'hui, vous ne pouvez plus être
souverain puisque les dans les
constitutions, il y a dans le préambule
de la Constitution comme valeur
supraitutionnel, donc plus fort que les
articles de la Constitution, il y a des
traités internationaux qui nous
empêchent d'avoir un contrôle des flux
migrateurs. Je sais que les frontières
vous intéressent moins que moi, mais je
pense que c'est quand même fondamental.
Les frontières nous intéressent que ce
soit en Hongrie ou l'amende qui paye
tous les jours ou des choses comme ça.
On s'intéresse à ça. Ça ça n'est qu'un
pris. Oui. Oui. C'est ce n'est qu'une
facette du prisme,
c'est-à-dire
bah il y a l'économie euh a tout il y a
d'autres d'autres facettes dans la
lecture générale bien sûr. Mais en tant
que géopolitologue, je me rappelle du
livre de Régis de Bré et au même et même
des écrits d'Ive Lacoste. La frontière,
elle est elle est elle est elle est
première la frontière. Une une nation
dont les frontières ne sont pas fixes ou
une entité comme l'Union européenne dont
les frontières ne sont pas délimitées.
Ça crée une guerre avec la Russie.
l'OTAN et le et l'Europe, leur problème
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas de
frontière. Ils ne veulent pas dire où
ils s'arrêtent et où il commence. C'est
l'origine du problème que nous avons
avec la Russie. Donc c'est quand même
très important les frontières. Mais
effectivement là vous si vous me mettez
sur un terrain économique qui n'est pas
le mien euh effectivement
vous je prétends pas je ne prétends pas
être un financier ou un économiste pour
ça humblement je vous dis. Donc si je
suis votre raisonnement, l'OTAN se
rapproche de la frontière russe. Je suis
je suis
très dangereusement.
Bah
pourquoi il fait ça ?
C'est l'OLI et c'est le c'est ce que
j'appelle la mutation globaliste de
l'Occident. L'Occident, c'est toute ma
thèse depuis des années, n'a plus aucune
signification
originelle. L'Occident d'ailleurs est
une notion qu'on peut déconstruire.
L'Occident aujourd'hui, c'est devenu
quoi ? marché des normes ou des valeurs
comme les droits de l'homme que l'on
viole allègrement dans dans les
différentes guerres unilatérales et
cetera. C'est le marché. C'est c'est ce
sont des définitions soit abstraites
normatives soit économiques. Mais il n'y
a plus aucune dimension identitaire dans
l'Occident. L'Occident n'est plus du
tout l'Occident européen façonné par les
Grecs, les Romains, le christianisme et
cetera. Il y a plus aucune dimension
identitaire.
D'accord ? Pourquoi l'OT l'OTAN pourquoi
l'OTAN va se gérer ? Et l'OTAN justement
comme l'Occident se définit se se
définit de plus en plus comme non
identitaire comme le monde we are the
word et bien il il ne peut pas
s'empêcher de s'étendre parce que
l'Occident se voit aujourd'hui comme le
monde. L'Occident se voit comme
l'international même mieux le global.
C'est euh l'Europe d'ailleurs comme une
sorte de laboratoire d'un futur
gouvernement mondial. C'est pas des
idées souverainistes extrêmes et cetera.
C'est Joe Biden lui-même. Il disait très
souvent au début de la guerre en
Ukraine, l'ordre international fondé sur
des règles et et l'Amérique global, il
parlait souvent de Global America, cette
OI parce qu'il reprenait l'expression
deckenbury et menacé. Donc ce sont des
gens qui pensent que si on refuse votre
système par la guerre ou par le refus
tout court d'une autre manière, vous
êtes un ennemi. L'ennemi c'est pas celui
qui attaque l'Occident. L'Occident
depuis très longtemps ne définit plus
comme l'ennemi celui qui l'attaque. Il
définit comme ennemi celui qui refuse
l'OIEL, celui qui refuse l'extension non
seulement de l'OTAN, mais de nos
institutions, de notre vision de
l'économie et surtout de de la de la
politique. Et et et c'est pour ça que
les occidentaux par des guerres de temps
en temps, mais souvent plutôt par de
l'ingérance et de l'ingénierie politique
et sociale, l'Occident n'a pas arrêté
dans le monde arabe avec Obama qui a
énormément aidé le Qatar et les frères
musulmans à faire ses révolutions
arabes, mais aussi les révolutions de
Volour. Ça a commencé en Serbie avec H
port et ça a continué ensuite. Ils ont
même essayé en Russie en 2012, ils ont
réussi en 2014 avec l'Ukraine. Ben ça a
provoqué une ou alors 2008 avec
Sachevilie en Géorgie. cette volonté que
l'autre me ressemble. Peut-être qu'ils
sont sincères, hein, d'ailleurs, on
n'est pas là pour juger les âmes, mais
c'est extrêmement dangereux quand quand
vous pensez que je suis le monde. Donc
si je suis le monde et que j'ai en fait
une manifeste Destinie parce que je suis
le meilleur système, je suis l'horizon
indépassable de la démocratie parfaite
du système de gouvernement le plus
merveilleux et mon alliance l'OTAN,
c'est l'OTAN global. C'est pas moi qui
le dit. Maintenant, vous savez que
depuis une dizaine d'années, l'OTAN
quand il se réunit depuis une dizaine
d'années dans son concept stratégique
annuel, de plus en plus élargit ses
missions en dehors de la zone
originelle. On a l'OTAN qui intervient
en Libye, on a l'OTAN qui intervient en
Afghanistan et on a l'OTAN qui veut
s'étendre jusqu'au précarse. Et donc ça
c'est belligène et la source pour
répondre à votre question, c'est que
nous sommes devenus totalement
mondialistes. L'Occident est devenu une
forme de mondialisme. Il y en a d'autres
hein. Il y a l'islamisme qui est
mondialiste. Il y a il y a a il y a pas
mal d'utopies mondialistes depuis
Voltaire et cetera. Nous nous sommes
devenus une utopie mondialiste. On a
confondu la mondialisation qui est un
échange entre personnes grâce à des
moyens de communication mais qui est
neutre, qui supprime pas la frontière.
Nous, on l'a confondu ou plutôt on a
pris le prétexte de la mondialisation
soi-disant heureuse pour dire et bien
puisqu'on est mondialisé, ben on va
faire le mondialisme. Or le mondialisme
c'est une idéologie qui veut être
planétaire et assurer l'extension de
normes partout qui sont nos normes,
puisque nous sommes nous, le monde.
Tandis que la mondialisation, elle a
permis à la Chine devenir encore plus
forte, plus impériale et elle a gardé
ses frontières et sa souveraineté. Donc
il y a ceux qui tigrent qui tirent
l'épingle du jeu de la mondialisation,
Chine, Turquie, Indonésie, ils se sont
modernisés, ils se sont libéralisés
économiquement, ils sont entrés dans les
échanges, mais ils sont devenus de plus
en plus identitaires et de plus en plus
nationalistes. Parce que par exemple,
Dogan, c'est un méchange de nationalisme
et de et de religieux et et de
néotomanisme. Donc c'est très
intéressant de voir comme le seul qui a
cru que le la mondialisation devait
déboucher sur une utopie mondialiste qui
va nous désouverainiser en tant que
nation, c'est le dindon de la farce
ouest européen. Parce que même pas
l'Est, les hongrois sont très
nationalistes. Les Américains restent
nationalistes, ils ont enveloppé leur
nationalisme avec l'OI, mais ils restent
nationaux impériaux. Les seuls qui
croient en cette utopie, c'est l'Europe.
Donc l'Europe va sortir de l'histoire
parce que vous voulez que je sois direct
dans votre réponse. L'Europe va sortir
de l'histoire. Elle est en train de
sortir de l'histoire et c'est pour ça
que le discours de JD Vanz à Munich en
février 2024 comme le le NSS hein la la
la stratégie nationale de sécurité
américaine l'a dit il y a quelques jours
et comme monsieur Trump l'a réitéré dans
Politico, il y a deux façons de voir la
chose. Casse-toi, tais-toi, je supporte
pas ton ingérence, qui es-tu pour me
donner des leçons de morale ? Ça, c'est
celui qui veut pas trop se faire
d'introspection. Et il y a l'autre façon
de se dire oui, peut-être qu'il se mêle
pas de ce qui le regarde pas. Il nous a
fait la guerre économique depuis très
longtemps, mais au moins, il nous
réveille. Il y a il y a on pourrait le
voir comme ça aussi. Il est en train de
nous alerter sur quelque chose. Euh il
nous traite de faible, de lâge, de tout,
de désouverainiser, de de
décivilisationnaliser et cetera et
cetera. Mais peut-être que c'est
l'occasion de se dire bah peut-être
qu'il y a un peu de vrai et et peut-être
qu'on va trouver un moyen de d'échapper
à ça. Mais nos élites globalistes sont
attachées mais d'une manière religieuse
à l'IEL. Et donc tout va être fait pour
empêcher les forces souverainistes. She
au Portugal,
Vox en Espagne, AFD en Allemagne,
monsieur Nigel Farage en en Angleterre
qui est sur le point d'arriver au
pouvoir puisqu'il est premier dans tous
les sondages. S'il y a des élections, il
gagne. Ils ont très peur, hein. Le les
globalistes ont extrêmement peur en ce
moment. Ils sont vraiment terrifiés
parce que ils sont sur le point
peut-être de perdre leur pouvoir dans
presque tous les pays européens. à part
la Belgique qui est un état alors là il
y a à la fois le siège de l'OTAN et la
Commission européenne. Donc là à part la
Belgique qui est le pays où il y a le
moins de pluralisme médiatique dans
toute l'Europe, c'est absolument
sidérant et j'y suis souvent. Donc j'ai
j'ai remarqué Monique le disait
récemment dans une interview à C News où
on était tous les deux en interview. Il
disait qu'il y a aucun pluralisme
politique mais à part la à part
Bruxelles enfin à part ils
appellent pas ça le cordon sanitaire.
Oui, en en Belgique, le cordon sanitaire
est sacré sacré. Mais dans la zone
francophone, par contre dans la zone
flamande, c'est carrément l'inverse
parce que toujours ils font l'inverse
des autres, hein. Le flamand et et le en
gros, le flamand fait ce que ce que fait
pas le le le le francophone. Mais
donc en gros, voilà, il y a le wallon et
le Bruxellois qui est une ancienne zone
flamande mais qui a été francophonisée,
ce qui énerve beaucoup les flamands
parce que Bruxelles c'est un stat. Selon
vous, selon vous cette organisation
Loyal
Oui.
Qui est encore bien achalandé en Europe.
Si des gouvernements conservateurs
montent au pouvoir, prennent le pouvoir,
arrivent à prendre le pouvoir,
l'Ol va éclater
ou l'OI va provoquer des troubles dans
le premier qui basculera.
Alors ça c'est certain. Par exemple, si
euh les souverainistes bien que modérés
du RN qui sont qui ont mis beaucoup
d'eau dans leur vin arrivent au pouvoir.
Je parlais de l'extrême gauche tout à
l'heure qui va essayer de de
déstabiliser avec un appel
révolutionnaire mais ils auront pas mal
de complices dans les milieux
médiatiques universitaires euh qui eux
sont attachés à l'IEL qui sont des
mondialistes beaucoup moins marxistes
ils vont se présenter comme démocrates.
Ils vont se présenter pour pour
démocrates en disant halte au fascisme,
il faut empêcher partout les moyens le
fascisme. Ils ont peut-être raison
peut-être, on ne sait pas hein. Nous on
est en géopolitique froide. J'ai un peu
comme vous la vision géopolitique
froide, on est'est pas là pour faire de
l'idéologie mais ce qui est certain que
euh il faut toujours se mettre à la
place de l'eau. Tout à l'heure, je
disais mettons-nous à la place du russe,
maintenant mettons-nous à la place des
défenseurs de l'IEL. Les défenseurs de
l'EL ont raison d'avoir peur, hein. Si
je suis un défenseur du globalisme
aujourd'hui, si je suis un défenseur de
l'UEL, je vais tout faire pour empêcher
l'accession de ces de de ces
souverainistes au pouvoir parce qu'en
plus, ils sont souvent neutres ou
prorusses. Pruss
d'être prorusses. En plus, ils veulent
un reset, ils veulent une entente avec
la Russie. Même s'ils sont pas
prorusses, c'est c'est pas un ennemi
existentiel pour eux. Or aujourd'hui,
l'ennemi russe c'est l'ennemi
existentiel utile qui permet de passer
en force le saut fédéraliste, le saut
fédéraliste propre à Mario Dragi qui l'a
même exprimé clairement. Euh c'est euh
c'est ça. D'ailleurs, comme madame
Meloni est arrivée au pouvoir, elle
était en train d'arriver au pouvoir en
Italie, Drag il a beaucoup conseillé, il
lui a dit "C'est très simple, tu veux
être adoubé par Clinton ? Moi, j'ai la
solution. Je t'amène voir sa femme qui
est italienne. Tu verras ensuite Clinton
euh pardon euh Biden, tu verras la femme
de Biden qui est italienne et Biden et
je vais t' doubrame Clinton. Et madame
Clinton était la première qui a dit
madame Mélonie tout à fait respectable,
faut la laisser, elle est peut-être pas
si fasciste que ça et cetera. Et il l'a
présenté aussi à des milieux européistes
et il lui a dit de prendre Georgetti qui
est le plus modéré de la Ligue Nord, qui
est un économiste libéral. Il lui a dit
"Tu prends Georgetti à l'économie, tu
deviens pro euh ukrainienne, atlantiste
à mort et euh euh très russophobe. Euh
même si tu le penses pas tout à fait, en
tout cas, tu joues à fond cette carte
très zelensne et cetera. Tu fais un
mande honorable avec l'Europe, tu dis
que tu veux pas sortir jamais de
l'Europe ni de l'euro et tu fais un
mande honorable auprès des démocrates
américains. Tu es à Doubé. Et c'est pour
ça que elle n'a plus rien à voir avec le
parti qu'elle avait avant d'arriver au
pouvoir. Elle s'est adaptée au système.
Donc il y a des souverainistes qui
arriveront au pouvoir mais par
opportunisme s'adapteront au système et
ils deviendront digestes par l'IEL. Et
il y a ceux qui voudront aller jusqu'au
bout de leur logique de
resouverainisation et ceuxl ils vont
avoir beaucoup de problèmes. Certains
seront même peut-être assassinés
physiquement.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Trois livres ? Oui, Paul Hazar. Paul
Lazar, la crise de la conscience
européenne, ce livre m'a marqué à vie.
un livre extrêmement intéressant qui
montre l'origine philosophique, les
grands voyages, l'origine géopolitique,
historique de cette crise de la
conscience européenne. Pour Lazar donc
bien sûr bien sûr Jjihad versus Macw de
Benjamin Barber, le grand sociologue
américain qui à la même époque que
Begjinski les années 96 97 traduit en
français un an plus tard, il disait
"Macord, c'est le mondialisme. produit
un déracinement djihad. Après, il a dit,
j'aurais dû prendre un autre mot. Il il
parlait pas que de l'islam. Il disait
djihad, c'est l'identité convulsive
revancharde qui se sent menacé par le
mondialisme. Et donc Jjihad va réagir à
McWord. Il annonçait Mad Max versus Oiel
ou reidentitarisation versus Oiel. Et
bien sûr le troisème
en toute modestie, c'est le mien, le
nouvel ordre post-occidental. Non, je
plaisante, je plaisante. Je sais, je
sais que vous allez me dire ça. Euh je
pense que le livre d'Obg Jinski est tout
de même, je sais que c'est une tarte à
la crème, c'est un lieu commun. Le grand
échiqué, c'est une tarte à la crème,
c'est un lieu commun mais il est
tellement intéressant et souvent on ne
dit pas le plus important dans ce livre.
Dans ce livre, ne parle pas que du
Heartland et cetera. Il dit "Je pense
que l'Europe n'a presque aucune chance
de redevenir souveraine au sens acteur
géopolitique. Et il dit pourquoi ?" Il
dit, "C'est pas ce que vous croyez,
c'est parce que elle est tellement
américanisée culturellement, il dit
lui-même, une culture pop américaine qui
n'est pas de très haute qualité ni
morale ni esthétique." Carrément, il le
dit très cyniquement. Mais cette
culture, elle a l'avantage d'être
addictive et d'être et et de faire appel
au désir. Cette culture a tellement
imprégné la pop culture américaine notre
et aussi il parle aussi d'Hollywood, il
parle de toute la tout toute le tout le
soft power culturel audiovisuel
américain, il dit ça a tellement
imprégné les consciences européennes
qu'elles ne pourront pas se rebeller
contre l'empire américain. Elles sont
cérébralement américaines, elles sont
affectivement américaines, elles sont
leurs neurones sont devenues américains.
Et ça, j'ai trouvé ça génial.
Bizarrement, c'est la partie dont on
parle le moins dans le livre de de
Bjegjinski, cet esclavagisme culturel,
ce que j'appelle l'empire cognitif
américain qui n'annexe pas des
territoires, il annexe des cerveaux. Et
là, bravo, on n'est pas là pour juger
moralement hein, moi je dis bravo. Une
efficacité extraordinaire ce que n'ont
pas les Russes. Les Russes n'ont pas le
soft power. Les Américains ont le soft
power. Ils ont la séduction. C'est
bizarre que vous parliez pas de Raymond
Aaron et de tout ce qui est républicain.
Oui. Démocratie, totalitarisme bien sûr.
Non, parce que vous me demandez les
livres qui m' m'ont le plus marqué, je
crois. Merci.
Oui. Alors ça c'est le mien. Mais vous
vous me demandiez les livres qui m'ont
le plus marqué, c'est ceuxlà. Paulzar
etjinski et Benjamin Barber.
Comment il s'appelle le vôtre ?
Le le motre le mien s'appelle le nouvel
ordre. Merci en tout cas pour le fait.
On vous devra des droits de c'est pas
trop dur.
le le nouvel ordre post-occidental. Non
mais il faut pas le bouger là parce que
là faut travailler deux fois là.
Pardon.
Impeccable.
Le nouvel ordre post-occidental et euh
comment le retour de Trump le retour de
Trump voilà le retour de Trump et la
guerre en Ukraine ont accéléré la
bascule géopolitique. Donc c'est un
livre sur le nouvel.
Est-ce que vous pouvez m'ouvrir et me
lire une page ?
Oui.
Là je vous ai pris à défaut. Vous avez
des pour lire d'habitude ?
Euh non mais je vois mal de loin mais
très bien de près donc ça va. Bit.
Exactement.
Miop
euh miop et et et astigmat.
Miop et astigmat en même temps.
Mais de près ça va. Alors
quand même hein. [rires]
Je je choisis ou j'ai la première page ?
N'importe quelle page.
D'accord.
On a dit n'importe quelle page sans
choisir.
J'ai le temps de choisir ou
bon je vais meubler pendant ce temps-là.
Soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous. Partagez nos vidéos, commentez, on
vous aime. C'est bientôt Noël. La
semaine prochaine, on vous réserve une
petite interview de notre cru. Vous vous
l'avez réclamé, on vous l'a fait venir.
Alexandreval, une un petit peu de
lecture.
Oui.
Allez.
Alors, de quoi parle-t-on ? Là, c'est un
chapitre sur l'Occident. De quoi
parle-t-on ? Commençons par le terme
Occident. Plus qu'ambivalent et
discutable dans ces emplois idéologisés.
Cette représentation au sens de force
motrice de l'histoire selon un autre de
nos maîtres, le géographe Yve Lacoste,
ne désigne plus dans son acception
géopolitique contemporaine une
civilisation européenne marquée par les
Celtes, la sagesse grèce grecque, le
droit romain, le christianisme et des
États-nations apparus à la suite des
invasions germaniques concomitantes avec
la chute de l'Empire romain d'Occident.
Excusez-moi, c'est long. Point. À
l'opposé cette à l'opposé de cette
acception qui est la première
civilisationnelle, existe une acception
contemporaine globaliste qui désigne un
système économico-financier et politico
stratégique qui évolue progressivement
vers une supraciété mondiale. Je
continue ou ça vous va ?
Il faudra engueuler l'auteur parce qu'il
y a pas assez de virgule dans toutes ces
phrases.
Ou j'ai mal lu. Je suis pas un très bon
lecteur. C'est possible que j'ai mal lu.
Euh est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ? une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose qui va rester
impérissable sur les réseaux et
peut-être quelque chose d'ailleurs qu'on
va réutiliser d'ici 6 mois ou un an
parce que quand on soit un stratège,
des fois il nous fait des bonnes
anticipations.
Oui. Ah ! Alors, un conseil ou une
anticipation ? Vous
un conseil et une anticipation ?
Alors, une anticipation là, c'est
facile. Je
pour les jeunes.
Ah, pour les jeunes. D'accord.
Une anticipation pour les jeunes pour
protéger les jeunes.
Pour protéger les jeunes.
Et ensuite, un conseil pour les jeunes
génération.
Je pense que les jeunes doivent se
durcir, pratiquer des arts martiaux les
plus létal le plus l'art martial le plus
réaliste possible style crave maga
réaliste ou les tal
parce que le crave maga il se fait
attraquer attraper par un judoca il
finit par queen par terre
ouais non mais parce que vous êtes pas
tombé sur un judoca
je suis pas d'accord
le mec du craf moi j'ai vu des mecs des
ceintures noires de judo les attraper et
en général ils finissent par terre il
pas du tout d'accord je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vous là la le le crave
Magas, il est pratiqué comme Richard
Douyeb, comme nos services euh euh
certains de nos services spéciaux euh et
comme l'école la vraie israélienne,
croyez-moi, c'est extrêmement létal ou
le close combat. En tout cas, faire des
arts martiaux, se durcir mentalement
parce que le monde va être de plus en
plus difficile. Ne pas vivre dans le
coton. Il faut savoir que dans les bons
lieux, souvent, on nous appelle les
fragiles. Donc, durcissez-vous. Je dis
surtout ça au au français en gros entre
guillemets de souche. Durcissez-vous.
Non mais durcissez-vous pourquoi ? Parce
qu'ils se font emmerdés. Durcissez-vous
intellectuellement par que pas
uniquement pour l'histoire du pain au
chocolat dans la rue. C'est pas ça. Mais
je pense qu'il il faut se durcir
mentalement parce que le monde va être
de plus en plus difficile. Il va falloir
être en bonne santé. Il va falloir avoir
du répondant et quand on fait quelque
chose de physique, ça aide le mental.
C'est surtout pour ça le mental, il est
pas durci que par le mental. Il est
aussi il y a une il y a une interaction
entre le corps et l'esprit. Donc ça je
pense qu'il faut se durcir. Nous allons
dans une société qui ressemblera dans 20
ou 30 ans à Mad Max.
avec les les les une telle popérisation
qui est peut-être des graves problèmes
énergétiques et autres où on sera dans
une société avec des prédateurs qui
seront de plus en plus capable de vous
agresser dans votre baignoire en gros
pour pour être je sais que ça fait un
peu populiste mais je m'en fiche je le
pense vraiment. Sinon un conseil vous
disiez un conseil
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Alors pour les un conseil plus
intellectuel celui-ci
acheter un chien c'est ça ? Non, si vous
voulez être désinformé, le meilleur
moyen journal de 20h, donc supprimer le
journal de 20h ou alors le compenser par
autre chose.
Pourquoi vous dites désinformé ?
Peut-être mal informé.
Alors justement la désinformation c'est
quelque chose qui est consubstantiel à
un journal de 20h sur une chaîne
publique. Puisque sur une chaîne
publique, le journal de 20h et c'est
normal, je m'en indigne pas, il ne peut
avoir que la voix officielle. Et donc
c'est de la désinformation puisque la
désinformation n'est pas un une fausse
information. une une désinformation,
c'est une information partielle qui va
être orientée à des fins politiques par
rapport au à l'état des lieux, aux
valeurs fondamentales ou à l'intérêt de
celui qui a le manche. Donc euh ou alors
s'il regarde le journal de 20h, regardez
Tinkerview ou regarder euh la chaîne
d'Abercane que j'aime beaucoup ou ma
chaîne, la chaîne Alexandre Delval qui a
pas du tout votre audience mais j'espère
qu'un jour elle l'aura.
Qu'est-ce que vous lisez comme presse ?
Alors, j'aime bien lire euh pour
vous informer.
Alors, je m'informe beaucoup en lisant
alors pour la presse qui dit pas
grand-chose, j'achète des journées tout
à fait des des journaux tout à fait
opposés. Alors, je vais vous étonner
peut-être, j'aime beaucoup le monde
diplomatique dans la presse qui est pas
ultra alternative mais un petit peu
parce que le monde diplomatique, c'est
pas du tout mon bord. B, pardon,
on les embrasse.
Oui. Euh, alors oui, je devrais pas
faire de pub pour un titre, mais si. Ah,
mais vous pouvez les embrasser aussi
avec nous, hein.
Voilà. Non, moi je les embrasse pas
parce que ils m'ont souvent allumé. J'ai
eu je suis pas un peu mao de les lire
peut-être mais il y a il y a des
articles de fonds très intéressants sur
la politique internationale. Je l'ai pas
du tout courrier international parce que
ils vous ont allumé.
Bah ils m'ont allumé parce que un moment
c'était islamophobe. Vous savez en
France vous parlez de l'islamisme, on
vous trait d'is islamophobe. Même mon
ami Rachid Kassi avait à l'époque avec
qui je bossais on a écrit un courant
fils d'imam algérien musulman. il était
islamophobe. Même même les frères
Bencher notamment l'ancien imam Souhab
Bencher, il était islamophobe. J'ai
appris ça dans le livre de Vincent
Gesser. Si vous voulez tout le monde est
islamophobe, y compris y compris les
imams. Vincent Gesser avait même dit que
Dalil Bou Baker, le recteur de la
mosquée de Paris était islamophobe.
Bref, voilà, c'était des polémiques.
Qu'est-ce que vous lisez d'autres ?
Alors, je lis parfois aussi euh très
souvent la presse italienne euh
notamment Folio. J'aime beaucoup il
Folio. J'ai de
droite,
pardon,
qui est de droite
euh qui est non le folio c'est très
complexe, c'est à la fois droite et
gauche. C'est c'est vraiment un mélange.
Parfois, je lis elle p parce que je suis
aussi elle piss parce que je suis
souvent en Espagne pour voir ce que dit
ben l'yel
et surtout je m'informe maintenant
énormément sur des des des blogs que je
étrangers de de toutes sortes de pays
que je fais traduire avec l'intelligence
artificielle et j'essaie de voir ce qui
se dit un peu partout. Voilà, dans dans
différentes dans différentes langues. Il
y a des langues à laquelles j'accède
aussi. par exemple la presse
brésilienne, je parle je parle pas très
bien portugais mais j'arrive à lire la
presse portugaise parce que c'est très
facile quand on parle l'italien et
l'espagnol. J'essaie de diversifier et
de piocher ce qui m'intéresse et et de
faire un tri. Alors si j'achète un
journal de droite, je vais acheter le
journal de gauche en même temps et je
vais faire un petit tri.
Comment on dit ? Comment ça va en
portugais ?
Ah com
bon ?
Est bon ? Est bon ? Como está ou está
bon ? Como está boudo bem? Posso falar
português se quer? Se você querá
não posso fazer palestra também na na
língua portuguesa porque fazo muitas eh
conferências e palestras no Brasil
também eh no Portugal e gosto muito da
da da língua portuguesa.
Um beijo e um abraço.
Um besinho. Bezinho.
Binho. Um petit biso c'est espagnol.
Bign.
Bignon. Revenons. Revenons à à nos
moutons. Est-ce que vous avez fini votre
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Vous avez rajouté un mot ?
Euh oui euh essayez de vous dédroguer.
Essayez de vous dédroger
voilà à desog Non, je dirais plutôt
essayer de vous dédroguer des réseaux
sociaux parce que moi je vois c'est une
véritable addiction extrêmement grave
mais mes élèves, je suis obligé
d'interdire ordinateur et réseaux
sociaux et téléphones sinon ils sont
happés. Un un de mes amis un jour est
venu m'espionner dans enfin il est venu
espionner ma salle de cours. Il était au
fond de la salle et après il m'a montré
une photo. Je croyais qu'il m'écoutait.
C'est mon orgueil. J'ai cru qu'ils
étaient passionnés par ce que je disais.
Ils étaient très calmes ce jour-là. La
photo par derrière montre qu'ils étaient
tous sur autre chose que le cours. Ils
étaient sur les réseaux sociaux. Donc
c'est un véritable c'est une véritable
drogue et il faudra un jour un
contrepouvoir parce que ça rend des gens
totalement liquéfiés. ce qu'on appelle
la la switch à liquida en Italie, c'est
une on est en train de liquéfier le
cerveau des jeunes et je leur dis pas
pour faire le vieux con qui juge
moralement moi-même parfois ma femme me
dit essaie de te essaie de laisser ton
téléphone. Donc je prêche pas que c'est
pas de la du moralisme mais c'est
vraiment leur cerveau va être liquéfié.
S'ils continuent dans ce sens, ils ne
seront plus capables d'avoir la moindre
concentration et ils n'apprendront plus
rien parce qu'ils auront des extensions
de mémoire mais sans leur outil, ils
seront totalement illétrés. Donc c'est
extrêmement grave et je les incite à
lire du bon vieux livre. Alors le mien
s'appelle cel
le nouvel ordre postcidental.
Merci. et et donc où ou les livres qu'on
a cité tout à l'heure, je pense que moi
je le vois par exemple quand je corrige
mon livre sur internet, je ne vois pas
les coquilles, c'est quand même
incroyable, je le corrige sur papier, je
vois des milliers de coquilles sur 600
pages, hein, ça montre bien quand même.
C'est pas pareil. Le le papier a quand
même quelque chose, faudrait l'expliquer
scientifiquement, je sais pas. Donc moi,
je les conseille de faire un minimum de
papier quand même, un minimum de
lecture.
Alexandre Del Val, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]